good morning everybody please take your
seats we've got to get this show on the
road
Welcome to the
Monday February 6th
session of the science technology and
energy committee
as is our custom we'll Begin by asking
everyone to rise and join
representative Tom closure as he leads
us in the pledge
certainly representative uh Reynolds
would you delete Us in the pledge
like
okay so we have a packed agenda today
we're going to try something new today
we have scheduled our bills on half hour
increments instead of one hour
increments
and what that likely means is that once
a public hearing starts for one bill if
it goes beyond a half hour the next
Bills
public hearing start will be delayed by
a small amount
and so that likely will happen but we'll
go with this and see how it works and
um
hopefully we won't miss our lunch
we have an executive schedule section
session scheduled for one o'clock and
that's a pretty hard start so we're
going to have to be on time got to keep
the trains running and to do that for
the morning session here I'm going to
turn the gavel over to our vice chair
representative Doug Thomas
welcome chairman Bose
thank you for your introducing House
Bill HB 458 and I will dispense with any
other words and saying you're on the
clock
thank you Mr Vice chair and good morning
members of the committee
the record I'm representative Michael
those I represent Rockingham District
five which is the town of Epping
and I serve as chair of this committee
I'm here this morning to introduce house
bill 458.
which is a bill relative to
participation in net energy metering by
small hydroelectric generators
the Genesis of this bill goes back a
long ways
to interconnection problems that have
Arisen in the area in the era of net
metering
for some small Legacy hydroelectric
generators
these generators frequently had more
than one Dam
that they use to generate electricity
but they had one interconnection point
to the grid
that made
each individual dams output
the governing factor and whether or not
they could participate in net metering
and accumulating those
loads together at the connection Point
turned out to be an important issue with
regard to net metering so that's how it
all got started
we passed legislation last year or the
year before I can't remember exactly to
allow
Monadnock paper which has three Mills
and one interconnection point to
accumulate
all of its load together
to qualify for net metering
this bill House Bill 458 does something
similar for another
hydroelectric facility up in Brookfield
New Hampshire
and
um or actually it's owned by a company
called Brookfield and I'm not entirely
certain exactly where all the dams are
located but the folks from Brookfield
who will testify later will tell you
exactly where they're all located
and what this bill does is something
similar to what we did for men had not
paper it allows the
output of the dams to be accumulated for
the purposes of net metering
the languages is very
tightly and carefully drawn in this bill
to
essentially apply only to this one
hydroelectric generator
and
it does provide a unique
situation for determining just exactly
how much power they are putting back
onto the grid
since it's difficult to meter it at a
single connection point
this bill provides a facility
if you look at lines on page one of the
bill lines 26 through 27 the
hydroelectric generator shall assume
liability for monthly meter reads and
providing all requisite billing
determinants and other necessary data to
the utility for billing purposes
including issuing net metering credits
the utility shall Bill according to the
information received from the
hydroelectric generator
but shall not be liable for the accuracy
of the meter reads or the ongoing
maintenance and performance of the meter
the hydroelectric generator getting
billed and receiving credits
pursuant to this provision shall be
subject to periodic audits
of the documentation and Records
associated with the meter reading
process to ensure compliance with all
statutes rules and tariffs
and the department of energy is going to
be involved here in determining and
authorizing
the method by which
these
calculations are made so that's kind of
the unique aspect of this particular
legislation
now I'm sure sure some of you are
wondering since this is a small
expansion of net metering
and I've been on record as saying that I
don't particularly favor expanding net
metering
why would I support this bill why would
I even introduce this bill well
I do support modest cautious and careful
expansions of net metering I've said
this publicly on many occasions
particularly when it supports our
hydroelectric Fleet
because our hydroelectric Fleet provides
run of river base load output
and I think that's important to
achieving reliability for the our
electric grid here in New Hampshire
so I think anything we can do to support
our hydroelectric Fleet is worthwhile
provided that we put safeguards in place
to make sure that it doesn't get out of
control
I worry about out of control net
metering based on the experience of
other states for example in California
this California Public Utilities
Commission just this past December
lowered that State's net metering tariff
by 75 percent
because they had determined
that net metering cost shifting was
raising electric rates in their state to
the point where it was
actually harming the state's efforts
to
electrify electrify its vehicle fleets
people were turning away from electric
vehicles because the cost of electricity
was so high
and they figured out after doing a lot
of studies that they needed to decrease
the net metering tariff
in addition California figured out that
net metering discouraged the purchase of
batteries
if it was more lucrative for you to
send your excess energy to the grid
rather than putting it at a battery
and that's what their previous tariff
did then people would not buy batteries
they just shipped their excess output to
the grid
so California said
for future net metering
customers you have to buy a battery if
you want to qualify for any net metering
and this is a reasonable policy it will
provide an incentive for the
proliferation of batteries
and Battery Technology can provide
new ways of doing business such as
transactive energy which is something
we're going to be talking about later on
in this session
so that's a long-winded way of
explaining why I support this
legislation
and I'm happy to introduce it
there is similar legislation in the
Senate that has already passed and we'll
be talking about that uh later on when
we have an exact session on this bill
but for now I'm going to stop and
accept questions from the committee
because I know there's a lot of people
behind us that want to speak about this
bill
thank you chairman Bose for your
excellent explanation and presentation
uh first question goes to representative
Bernardi
thank you Mr Vice chair Mr chair are you
aware of any other hydro small-scale
hydro facilities that may be in similar
circumstance looking in the future for
this type of uh uh special exemption
I am not aware of any other facilities
that face this problem and could benefit
from this solution no
thank you
representative Winnie Thomas
thank you um
Bill actually sounds like a pretty good
idea I do have one question on page two
line six through
H where it says the utility shall
recover the incremental costs for this
manual billing process as well as all
net meter and credits issued pursuant to
this provision from all utility
customers my question is do you have an
estimation of how much utility bill
utility bills would increase because of
this action
no but that is problematic language and
um
there are a couple of potential
solutions to that
to that issue for example that
language could be changed to read the
utility shall recover the incremental
cost for the manual billing process as
well as net metering credits pursuant to
this provision
as determined by the commission the
commission being the the Public
Utilities Commission
the reason this language is potentially
problematic is that it applies only to
utility customers and
could exclude
the community power aggregation
customers that soon will be
coming on board in
fairly substantial numbers so this is
something that we're going to take a
close look at and when it comes to
Executive session time I may be offering
an amendment to make some changes to
this language does that answer your
question that does thank you thank you
representative Harrington
uh yeah thank you thank you for taking
my question just as a follow-up to that
when this as it's stated right now it
says all utility customers does this
mean default service customers only or
is it anybody that gets a bill from a
utility company
are you talking about the the last part
of the line on yeah the one we just
discussed in line eight there which is
from all utility customers is that
default service customers only or is
that everybody who is signed up with a
utility for distribution services as
well yes I think that applies to all
utility customers and that's the Crux of
the issue here so okay all right so I
just want to thank you okay
representative muns
thank you Mr chair and uh thank you for
taking my question
um the language includes energy storage
facilities it seems that's a new new
phrase in the in the in the section
what's the reasoning for that
it's on line six
page one or page two uh page one
oh yes I see the the reference you're
talking about
that was
um language that was suggested to apply
and there is further there's language
further on
that
says that
nothing in this provision shall be
deemed to approve or allow the
participation of energy storage
facilities and net energy meeting
metering unless otherwise approved or
Allowed by law or an order or decision
issued or rule adopted by the department
of energy of the Public Utilities
Commission
so it permits the use of
energy storage as long as that's energy
storage
is carefully determined by the
department of energy or the Public
Utilities Commission to be able to
participate in net energy metering
thank you thank you uh representative
for your testimony I'd like to uh move
on to our next presenter which will be a
calling on Mr Griffin robush the pro
Department of energy who has a different
point of view
thank you uh chairman Thomas members of
the committee for the record Griffin
Roberge from the New Hampshire
Department of energy the department is
opposed to House Bill 458 is introduced
for background the statute permits a
hydroelectric generator with a total
Peak capacity at or below one megawatt
that began operation before July 1 of
2021 and shares equipment or facilities
with other generators or electric
utility customers for interconnection
shall be able to participate in net
energy metering
um House Bill 458 modifies the statute
as you'll see in the bolded language but
uh specifically on lines 12 to 14 it
permits those hydroelectric facilities
to be eligible as a customer generator
as a matter of law without regard as to
whether such hydroelectric generator is
the electric utility customer account of
record at the point of interconnection
to the electric grid the remaining
language spells out a process by which
the hydroelectric generator would submit
information to the department regarding
the facility's proposed methodology for
reading and documenting meter data
um the department understands the
Genesis of this bill stems from a couple
of hydroelectric facilities owned by
Brookfield Renewable that are located
behind the meter at White Mountain paper
in Gorham New Hampshire on paper white
Mount the company White Mountain paper
is the customer generator as they are
the interconnection point for the
hydroelectric facilities again located
behind the meter how the that Hydro
those hydroelectric facilities sell
their power is outlined in existing
power purchase agreement that was
reached by consensus amongst both
private parties the White Mountain paper
company and Brookfield Renewable as far
as doe understands this is the only
arrangement in the state that this bill
would impact but we are firmly opposed
to the proposed language change on lines
12 to 4 as it fundamentally undermines
the current statute by allowing a
hydroelectric generator itself to be
considered a customer generator in short
the bill looks to remove the term
customer from customer generator despite
the Hydra your electric generator being
a customer of the utility
customer generators within statutory
limits are allowed to net meter their
renewable energy generation back to the
Grid at the customer level this bill
proposes to allow the hydroelectric
facility itself a generator that
currently exists behind the meter at
White Mountain paper to act as a
customer generator
doe would respectfully contend that any
characterization that this bill is a
technical fix a minor change or a
cleanup from previous legislation is
wholly inaccurate the bill does not
incentivize any new generation or
directly lower electric rates the
department submits that this bill
represents a significant policy change
for legislators to consider enacting
this change does create a precedent for
other facilities to capitalize on the
benefits of net energy metering and may
open the door for future legislative
attempts to slowly chip away at the
definition of customer generator
as previously stated doe believes this
bill stems from an existing power
purchase agreement again between two
private parties group field renewable
and White Mountain paper in Gorham New
Hampshire only one party to date
Brookfield Renewable has been attending
public hearings for an amendment that
was proposed last year on this issue as
well as the legislation currently before
you
um it is our understanding that White
Mountain paper is just now becoming
aware of House Bill 458's existence and
its proposed changes and I believe they
have representation here today who can
speak to the company's observations of
the bill there may be a potential
non-legislative solution to this issue
around customer generator which may be
addressed through negotiations again
through two private parties who reached
a who reached an agreement on an
existing power purchase agreement this
concludes my testimony on this bill and
I'm certainly willing to answer any
questions
thank you uh Mr robarge
seeing one question from representative
Summers
thank you Mr chairman just a quick
question I I know it doesn't mention in
a mountain here but is there any idea of
how much the utility Administration
costs would add to the rate payers
expense thank you for the question I
unfortunately couldn't answer that
question that might be something to ask
the utility that overlooks this
Arrangement thank you representative
Harrington
thank you and I think you think my
question uh this kind of I'm wondering
does this open the door now we're taking
uh one particular group here with two
private individuals as you said and with
changing law just to make it life better
for at least one of them I guess how
many other uh examples might be floating
around out there where we're going to
have one or two companies or private
individuals that we change the law for
in order to make their life better sure
thank you for the question as as I
mentioned uh the department believes
that this bill as it's currently written
would only impact
um the arrangement between Brookfield
Renewable and White Mountain paper we
the department just wants to strongly
note two policy makers such as such as
those in this committee that this does
open the door for watering down the
definition of customer generator
it does open the door to give private
entities the opportunity to maybe submit
legislation in the future to maybe water
down current statutory Provisions around
customer generator the department wants
to strongly convey that to this
committee that that is an implication
with the thing under consideration today
uh representative bones
thank you Mr chair
um thank you for taking my question and
I apologize it's it's still early so I'm
trying to figure out all this there's a
lot to unpack in your in your testimony
um and what I'm trying to understand is
if these two organizations have an
agreement already why why do why is
there a need for this legislation what
what is what are they I think that might
be a question to ask the private parties
thank you yep that's that's appropriate
thank you thank you
see any questions thank you Mr Roberts
thank you move on to the next presenter
and that would be uh Heidi Kroll please
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Heidi Kroll I work at Gallagher kalihana
gartrell and I'm here today on behalf of
both Brookfield Renewable as well as
Monadnock paper mills with me is Steve
zeretti from Brookfield Renewable
um uh
with the government relations uh
division we are in support of
um House Bill 458 and I think we can
answer a lot of the questions that have
been raised so far in terms of the
legislation so
um this bill is with respect to
existing Hydro facilities it's amending
existing law RSA 362 a colon 9 Roman 20.
um and it's attempting to
um amend this law so that it can
actually be implemented this law
originally was passed with passage of SB
91 in 2021 that was a bill that had
bipartisan support and it was signed at
a signing ceremony that the governor
held both for SB 91 and House Bill 315
which was the bill that allowed
Municipal net metering and again that
was back in August of 2021 and as
representative Vos or chairman Vos
mentioned the original intent of SB 91
was to try to address
the situation that two Hydro facilities
here in New Hampshire have and both
Monadnock paper mills and Brookfield
Renewable have multiple Hydro facilities
behind a a meter that's a single
interconnection point so in the case for
example I'll give you Monadnock paper
mills first they have three Hydro
facilities each are below one megawatt
they're individually licensed by ferc
they're individually certified by the
puc to produce Rex by all other measures
they are Standalone facilities but they
interconnect and feed their power
through Manana paper mills and then mad
knock paper mills is the single point of
interconnection to the grid
similarly Brookfield Renewable has
actually six Hydro facilities behind the
retail meter as you heard it's White
Mountain paper up there they have six
Hydro facilities behind the meter
four of those Hydra facilities are under
five megawatts two are above five base
slightly above five megawatts
um
so originally when we passed SB 91 it
was to address the problem uh eversource
was looking for clarification
um what they were saying is that when we
look at the single point of
interconnection in the example for
example of monadnaught paper mills we
can't tell really whether it's three
separate separate Hydro facilities that
are each under one megawatt and as we
know anything under one megawatt
qualifies for net metering or does it
really kind of looks to us like it might
just be one single Hydro facility
because it's coming through one single
point of interconnection and so they
were just looking for clarity
um
so we passed uh SB 91 again as I said in
2021 again it would it was had
bipartisan support and the idea was
simply to try to level the playing field
so that these high two cases of hydro
facilities that had this problem could
participate in net metering and with the
passage of House Bill 315 Municipal
group net metering like any other Hydro
facility is able to enjoy
after the passage of SB 91 both entities
approached eversource
to start the paperwork if you will in
terms of trying to net meter or group
net meter and eversource identified an
additional problem fair enough
um there the additional problem was in
the case of Brookfield like I mentioned
they have the six Hydro facilities four
are eligible for net metering and two
are not
in addition they have as you've heard
they have a purchase power
contract purchase power agreement with
Whitefield a white mountain paper and
that's a long-term contract and their
first and foremost obligation is to have
the output of the mill output of the
hydro facilities
supplying the load of the mill and so
again with net metering it's really only
excess generation that's not being used
use behind the meter that would
potentially be eligible for for net
metering and so and in the case of
Monadnock paper mill they have in
addition to their three Hydro facilities
they have a on-site steam turbine runs
off of waste heat from the mill
um when the mill is running that steam
turbine is running they're using all of
their Hydro that needs about 50 percent
of their power needs they buy the other
50 from the competitive market but at
any rate Hydra eversource was looking
for a methodology which is spelled out
in this piece of legislation a
methodology which Oliver simplifying to
say that is kind of like a fancy
spreadsheet where you're metering the
output of each Hydro facility
um looking at what's being used on site
and then making sure that anything that
is coming out onto the grid any kilowatt
hours that um that you're being clear
that if it's going to be if those
kilowatt hours are going to be net
metered that they're coming from
eligible at net metered eligible
facilities so in the case of Brookfield
screening out any power that's coming
from the two facilities that are greater
than five megawatts
um
so that is the intent of this
legislation is to try to address that
additional problem that we didn't
foresee when SB 91 was passed we did
work closely with
um and as you heard there's there was
efforts last year and we worked with a
variety of parties eversource doe and
the chairman Vos
um
this year as well we went back with
eversource and worked through this
language so the language that is in
house bill 458 we did work very closely
with eversource on and they are
comfortable with that language
um
so I just wanted to mention that as well
and
um the other thing I would say
um two other things actually one with
the net metered power that would be
coming from the Brookfield facilities
any excess that's not being used to
serve White Mountain paper that power
would be eligible for the municipal
group net metering program again which
was passed with bipartisan support and
signed by the governor at the signing
ceremony in August of 2021 that was
House Bill 315 so that's as you know
political subdivisions municipalities
schools the state counties that are
eligible under that program
final thing I want to say and then I'll
turn it over to Steve to add some
additional remarks this language has
been very very narrowly tailored to
address these two situations and if you
look at the beginning of the law or
beginning of the legislation we're
talking about a hydroelectric generator
with a total Peak generating capacity
that is at or below the capacity
eligibility requirements set forth
already in law so again that's one
megawatt or less serving
um
municipalities
um as well and other political entities
as well as businesses if you're over one
megawatt you can only serve under the
municipal net metering program and that
first became operational before July 1st
of 2021 and that shares equipment or
facilities with other generators energy
storage facilities or electric utility
customers for interconnection to the
electric grid and so that basically
means to say only the two situations
that we know of that have this problem
of sharing a single interconnection
point with the grid so it is um very
narrowly tailored
and with that I'll turn it over to Steve
thanks Heidi good for the record I'm
sorry could you uh say your full name
please yep uh good morning Steve zaretti
with Brookfield renewal
um I guess I'd first reinforce what what
Heidi described some questions around
the arrangement between Brookfield and
White Mountain paper without getting
into details of a private arrangement I
would just reinforce that the intent of
this legislation and the entirety of the
discussion we've had around it publicly
and privately is focused entirely on
excess generation unallocated under the
PPA so there was no intent on
brookfield's part to not continue to
serve the mill or to not continue to
serve our contractual obligations under
that PPA so that is unaffected as part
of this we acknowledge that the
discussion here and in fact the language
described is focused on excess
Generation
Um and I think when you look at the the
language in the proposed legislation
where it talks about the methodology
energy that would have to be captured
with the does input that is really
acknowledging that there needs to be an
identified
methodology for understanding what is
and isn't eligible so what is serving
the load as first priority and then what
is being exported to the grid and of
that exported energy what is coming from
the the hydros that are below five
megawatts and that would ultimately be
eligible and then above five megawatts
of course would not so I just want to
clarify that piece first on the customer
generator piece you know that was
something that we hadn't anticipated we
did work on SB 91 and had expected to
enroll a portion of these projects when
we worked with eversource we determined
or they determined that there would be
an issue there and we've worked
collaboratively with them since to
identify language that would work for
project enrollment in our view in the
absence of that language for
participation in the program there's
really only a couple ways that we would
pursue that which is one would be
implementing costly infrastructure to
interconnect these stations individually
which sort of undermines the intent of
the original enabling statute or for
Brookfield to take on the customer
obligation at the point of
interconnection which would be
an odd Arrangement as we're an
unaffiliated entity from the the mill
itself so happy to answer whatever
questions but I did just want to clarify
those two pieces up front
thank you both of you a question from
representative
Coleman
Carmen sorry
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I just want to make
sure I understand we're talking about
four facilities altogether uh but at
least 10 megawatts of power of
generation power because two of them are
at least five megawatts the others are
under one so somewhere I don't know 10
to 14 total
and much of that power is going to be
used by White Mountain paper and then
the rest would go onto the grid so are
we anticipating that that amount that
goes onto the grid is always going to be
under five megawatts or or not so that's
that's kind of the point of the language
where it defers to the doe to establish
a methodology for determining what is
and it isn't eligible Supply so there's
a couple ways that you you could do that
and I won't you know at this point uh
assume what the the outcome of that
would be but that is the point of that
to make sure that nothing that would be
eligible for the program is coming from
a project that is size greater than the
program limit
thank you uh representative poche
thank you chair and thank you for taking
my question
um
when I first read this
I didn't see an issue
now with three testimonies
I've heard that this would not affect
proliferation
I've heard that this might open statutes
very strongly
suggesting that
along with uh
another suggestion which is my question
thank you
the suggestion was that the two parties
possibly could come up and solve this
issue without legislation
your view on that is that possible
um well I don't I don't want to
discuss sort of a private Arrangement
publicly and I don't want to speak on
behalf of White Mountain paper
but in our view that would require some
type of amendment to the PPA which has
all along been something that we're
looking to avoid here we're not looking
to make any changes to the existing
agreement we want to keep that in place
as is and so any changes would either
require some type of change to the PPA
or some additional administrative burden
on White Mountain paper which is also
what we would like to not see here so
this in our view is the most streamlined
way of keeping the contract unaffected
but enabling what we think was in part
the intent of SB 91 to be
operationalized
uh thank you representative Harrington
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question a little confused
here you seemed like you're saying you
went into a voluntary contract between
two private parties and now rather than
go back and we negotiate the contract
you want us to pass a law that among
other people requires me to pay a higher
electric bill uh because it's all
utility customers so why should I pay a
higher electric bill because you don't
want to negotiate a contract
the contract I don't think is
necessarily relevant here because the
point of this is about the excess
generation that's not allocated to the
contract
so we're not looking to make a change to
the contract we don't think we need to
make a change to the contract so that's
not the the intent of of this
follow-up follow-up would you be open to
saying instead of all utility customers
that the two parties involved pick up
all the costs associated with this
rather than passing it on to some
retired grandmother in Manchester
foreign
I think there are a couple things I just
wanted to kind of be clear so
first of all with the passage of House
Bill 315 we authorize the state
authorized Municipal net metering so any
facility between one megawatt and five
megawatt Watts whether it's Hydro or
solar or any other renewable can serve
political subdivisions as it's defined
in that Municipal net metering law so
um
what Brookfield is looking for under
this legislation is the same ability
that other Hydro facilities and other
renewable generators already have which
is to use the excess generation so that
the generations that's not already
earmarked for White Mountain paper under
the purchase power agreement
what is excess to be able to allocate or
have the opportunity for that excess to
be used in the municipal net metering
program
um so to the extent that do you think
there are costs associated with that
um
I think the idea here is just to try to
level the playing field so that it this
Hydro facility could participate just
like others are allowed to
um with respect to the
um well anyway I guess I'll leave it
there I don't know if I've answered very
quickly well
um you can have a follow-up when someone
else asks questions okay representative
uh Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman following up on
that question isn't
the cost of
Counting the comings and the goings the
kilowatt hours administering net
metering already a cost that
all of our utilities
there and already include
in um
in customers bills on the principle that
net metering renewable energy is a
benefit to Consumers
that is my understanding yes
thank you
representative Bernardi
thank you Mr Vice chair so regarding SB
91 uh
your written testimony now indicates
that the Berlin Gorham situation was a
driver of that yet in your testimony two
years ago it never appeared is never
mentioned can you explain that
disconnect
um so at least on brookfield's part I
can say that we did submit testimony to
this committee uh in favor of SB 91 and
uh described the implications for our
composite
oh specifically uh focusing in on Berlin
and Gorham it was not mentioned before
but now is
same answer so we did testify before the
committee you may be confusing that with
banana paper which was also discussed
um in in committee but we did work
actually with Monadnock paper on that
legislation and testified before the
committee thank you yeah we'll take one
last follow-up from representative
Harrington
and I'll be quick Mr chairman thank you
uh you mentioned uh uh
municipals municipalities in your
previous statement uh in response to my
question
I'm a little confused I thought these
are two private parties where which one
is Municipal uh so the the point would
be to enroll the projects or the access
output from the projects into the
municipal group net metering program so
that the the beneficiaries of that
enrollment would be municipalities and
other political subdivisions
okay thank you for your testimonies uh
well explained I'm going to invite Mr
koozie
up next
representing White Mountain
uh good morning Mr Vice chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
David cuzzy with Prospect Hill
strategies here in town uh this morning
here on behalf of White Mountain Paper
Company
White Mountain Paper Company at this
time does not have a position on the
bill
largely that is because as
Mr Roberts mentioned the company
just became aware of the legislation I
just began working with the company a
few weeks ago
and as Miss Kroll mentioned all the
stakeholders that were in discussions
going back to last year
uh White Mountain paper was not among
those even though
uh we're a pretty significant
stakeholder here which is not a
complaint just a statement of fact uh
that being the case uh White Mountain
paper thinks that uh for all the points
of discussion made this morning that it
it would maybe make sense to have the
benefit of some time
so that we can engage with Brookfield
and others and also internally
decide what uh if any are the impacts
both in terms of the current agreement
but also uh
what may be the impact down the road
once this agreement which I believe the
PPA expires in 2030 I I I make okay uh
in 2030 uh obviously that uh that
generation is the lifeblood of the mill
and so there are there are those
implications that the company would like
the benefit of of understanding both
internally and into discussions with
with Brookfield and others so I do know
uh as previously mentioned sb40 is
already on its way from the Senate which
is companion legislation and I would uh
respectfully suggest that
um if that if it's possible that maybe
that be the vehicle that is utilized
because that will be worked on in the
spring that'll give us several weeks a
couple months to
better determine uh how we feel about
this we White Mountain paper feel about
this uh and and see if there's a a path
to Yes uh on that and with that Mr
chairman I thank you uh and happy to
answer any questions the best I can yes
I will I will take Liberty to ask us one
question which I'm sure others may ask
the same question as before do you
believe that we need legislation in or
can this be worked out offline and thank
you for the question Mr Vice chair
respectfully I I think I don't I don't
know
um and so that is why uh at the that is
why we don't have a position but why we
also think
this would benefit from some time
thank you representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question could you elaborate a
little bit more on how the EPA fits into
this
uh thank you for the question I I
wouldn't I wouldn't be in a position to
uh to elaborate on that I apologize we
can we can uh get you that that answer
thank you
representative munz thank you Mr chair
and uh thank you for taking my question
um in the research that you've done
since becoming aware of this
um did you did you find out if there has
been any
um attempts to address this
administratively going to the Department
of energy to puc you know that type of
thing on behalf of white mountain or
just just generally generally yeah
I I I can only speak to White Mountain
we're not aware of uh White Mountain has
not been a part of any of those
discussions I know
um
Department of energy also reached out to
see if if the company just a matter of
uh a week or two ago or something along
those lines to see if the company had
had a chance to look at the legislation
that would be the extent as far as I
know uh of White Mountains
administrative exploration I guess for
lack of a better way to phrase it
thank you
thank you Mr kessie for your testimony
we're going to move along now thank you
and I'm going to call on Mr Michael
licato from eversource
foreign
for the record Michael Licata
representing eversource energy
just want to start off by saying that
eversource is in support of this
legislation we do appreciate the
Outreach uh
to us to to work on the language and get
it um to a place that we think uh is
really uh narrowly focused on fixing a
metering issue
and making sure that these two Hydro
facilities are able to
participate in state net metering as
authorized by SB 91 in in 2021
um I guess we we respectfully disagree
with our friends at the department of
energy that this is a a broader more
expansive
piece of legislation from the company's
perspective the challenge is that
um as Miss Kroll described you have two
facilities with multiple
two locations with multiple generating
facilities that are located behind the
eversource retail meter and in order for
them to participate in net metering as
previously authorized the company needed
to determine how to essentially read
those meters those are privately owned
meters they're Revenue grade meters
which means they're they're highly
accurate and able to participate in
Regional markets but
the clarity that is being sought by by
this legislation is
um who owns the meter who reads the
meter who maintains the meter who
ensures the accuracy of the meter and
that really is what uh is sought to be
answered by this legislation
and so as the legislation contemplates
the customers who own the meter uh the
generator excuse me who owns the meter
would be responsible for for reading it
and then submitting that information to
eversource the utility on a monthly
basis in a manner that is agreed to by
the department of energy
so obviously looking at the on-site
generation what is excluded from
uh from net metering because it it might
be either a technology that doesn't
qualify or the size of the facility that
doesn't qualify uh and then the utility
uh takes that information as described
in the bill and Via a manual process
would apply those uh net metering
credits to to the accounts and I would
just note that
all group net metering all Municipal net
metering is a manual process for the
utility it's all done via spreadsheet by
individuals on a monthly basis this
would be no different and just uh answer
what I imagine is a question that I will
get asked about the costs associated of
of administering that
I don't have that information because
obviously it depends on the methodology
and the process that gets approved by
the Public Utilities Commission by the
department of energy however we
certainly do not believe that it will be
a significant cost driver again you're
talking about an individual
taking a spreadsheet applying it through
our Billing System in a manual process
that's not big dollars but it was
important to us to have that
language included in the legislation
because this is a unique circumstance
and
10 years from now 20 years from now uh
you know having that legislative
record is is important for future future
rate cases and future cost recovery so
with that I'd be happy to answer any
questions
that I can
thank you Mr locata good to see you here
I'm going to call on representative
Harrington
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
I think I got this correct you're going
to be able to somehow collect all your
costs associated with this and as
written you would then distribute those
costs over all the rate payers for
eversource and couldn't it just as
easily be sent to the people benefiting
from this uh new law rather than have
well have me pay iron electric bill
um
so you are correct
um the company's interpretation as
written is that it would be collected
from all distribution uh customers so I
know the question came up about whether
it was a default service or or all
customers this would is written um all
distribution customers
um
you know I it could certainly be written
um I think you would need to amend the
language though and and make it very
specific to the the billing process
um right now that includes all net
metering credits so you know if if the
customers were paying for the net
metering credits that they received it
just sort of cyclical right it doesn't
do what it's intended to do
um but you know I can't speak to the
company uh the two companies
um other interest or ability to uh
absorb those manual billing costs again
we do not expect them to be significant
see any other questions thank you Mr
Lakota for your testimony seeing no
other pink cards here I
the uh no other speakers so I will close
the public hearing on HP 458
and ask representative project to
present the blue sheet comments
representative closure you have some
information for us foreign thank you
chair
on House Bill 458 the blue sheet there
was two in favor none opposed
online it was 28 in favor none opposed
thank you we appreciate that
I would like next to open a public
hearing on House Bill 381 and call to
the testimony table the bills Prime
sponsor representative Michael
Harrington
foreign
just to give the committee an update we
are now officially one half hour behind
schedule
thank you Mr chairman I'll do my best to
make this very fast then uh fairly
simple issue you know if it walks like a
duck and quacks like a duck it's
probably a duck so if it acts like a tax
it probably is a tax what this bill
simply says is that if you want to
adjust the system benefits charge you
need it was established by Statute if
you want to make it higher or lower then
you change the statute you don't
delegate that authority to anybody else
it has to go back through the general
court or it is allowed for authorization
by the fiscal Committee of the general
court as well as the is the court itself
so that's that's it not complicated
okay thank you for introducing
introducing House Bill 381 questions
from the committee representative
McWilliams has a question uh thank you
chair thank you representative
Harrington for presenting this bill I do
have a question about what it looks like
for the fiscal committee to approve it
can you just walk me through what that
process would be
I I would thank you for the question but
I'm not going to try to quote the exact
process because I don't have it
memorized but there is a process that
the fiscal Commit This is not new to
this bill it's it's a process that's
used uh
quite often for different things
follow up follow up
so
so having gone through this with the
State Building Code every three years
when we update the State Building Code
it requires the the updated Bill to go
through Edna right a house committee
then to get approved by the house and
the Senate and then sign into law by the
governor and we've had problems in the
past with the state building code where
we were approximately nine years behind
the rest of the country because we
couldn't come to a consensus on updating
the state building code for construction
and so it just lagged and lagged and
lagged do you see something like that
becoming an impediment with this bill
because we can't get our act together as
a legislature
not at all because first of all it's the
function it's the purpose of the
legislation we get elected in one of our
most important duties that we have is to
decide who's going to get taxed and how
much so the system benefit charge is a
fancy name for a tax we're taking money
away from people they have no choice
they want to have electricity they have
to pay it so I just think the
legislature should look at it and if we
decide that it needs to be increased or
decreased or just stay the same that's
fine there's no impediment there's no
codes involved this is strictly at the
discretion of the legislature and I
don't see that as being an issue
thank you additional questions from the
committee
seeing none I told you would be quick
I'll thank representative Harrington for
introducing the Senate Bill uh House
Bill 381 and I'll next call on and I'll
remind representative Harrington that he
needs to fill out a pink card
and
and then I'll call to the testimony
table the representative from the
Department of energy Mr Griffin Roberts
foreign
thank you chairman Vos uh members of the
committee again for the record Griffin
Roberge New Hampshire Department of
energy uh doe is uh neutral on this bill
as introduced
um for context this bill amends State
Statute that was created by House Bill
549 last year that statute codified the
rate at which the system benefits charge
is set and is increased in the future
the bill was passed by the legislature
in response to puc decisions to alter
the funding levels for
um from the SBC to the state's Energy
Efficiency programs that are managed by
the utilities here in the state
under uh House Bill 549 from last year
the legislature clearly established what
the system benefits charge level should
be per that bill the portion of the
system benefits charge shall be adjusted
annually using the most recently
available three-year average of the
Consumer Price Index plus a quarter of a
percent
um the bill would remove this language
that allows for an uh this kind of
escalator in the system benefits charge
and require any increase to the system
benefits chart should be done through
legislative approval either through
legislation as uh as this committee
regularly does or through the uh joint
legislative fiscal committee
we do want to inform the committee that
should the bill forward uh wrapping on
uh representative McWilliams question
further Clarity around the joint
legislative fiscal committee approval
path would be welcomed as a committee
knows state agencies and departments
bring forward items to the Joint
legislative fiscal committee for review
should an increase be made is the fiscal
committee coming from a state agency or
a state department
um if it does fall to say doe or the puc
how would we know when to bring an item
is there some other route that the
legislature would like the fiscal item
to appear before the fiscal committee
these are just some of the questions
that the department would respectfully
encourage the committee to consider
should it move forward with this bill
um and that really concludes my
testimony and I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you for your and the Department's
perspective on this issue representative
Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Roberts for taking my question uh so
as as I'm seeing this it's possible that
we can have a scenario where the
legislature fails to update the system
benefits charge as the Consumer Price
Index goes up and up and up uh would
that mean that that effectively then the
value of the SBC going into Energy
Efficiency is is it being lowered then
in effect thank you for the question so
based on our read of the bill it does
not lower the system benefits charge in
any way shape or form it keeps it static
as to where it currently is it prevents
any further the bill prevents any
further increase to the system benefits
charge
um absent legislative approval
um so again under current statute is
that the SBC is allowed to increase
um based on the available three-year
average of the CPI plus a quarter of a
percent under this bill again that
language would be removed funding level
remains where it is it will not change
unless legislative approval is made
follow up right but my concern is is
more about
um if the SBC stays the same but prices
continue to increase does that lower the
effective value of the SBC what the
amount of energy efficiency that we can
buy okay I'm sorry is decreasing yep I
apologize I understand your question now
um that is a potential obviously in
inflation increases cost for goods
Supply services and that type of thing
um that is obviously a policy
consideration for uh this committee to
consider uh but again House Bill 549
um was a clear demonstration by the
legislature last year that they wanted a
role in setting the system benefits
charge so Falls to policy makers to make
that decision thank you for the question
representative Nutter has a question
I did but I just found it on my phone
thank you
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
um forgive me if I'm uh forgetting
something from our orientation sessions
but
um the um this this bill is only talking
about the Energy Efficiency component of
the SBC that's correct how how what what
percentage of the total SBC does that
represent if I could I could I'd love to
follow up with you on that I don't have
that data available here but I'm sure it
varies across uh utility to utility but
that can check on that thank you thank
you
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman very just a very
quick clarification question is that
you're understanding that in the New
Hampshire Constitution it states that
the State House Representatives controls
the purse of the State of New Hampshire
but I I am thank you for the question I
am not a constitutional expert so I I
guess I would defer to your
um judgment on that thank you
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um
if we capped this
the charge at 2020 levels
see how that would directly impact
Energy Efficiency in New Hampshire sure
uh thank you for the question so
um
if this bill were to move forward and
funding levels remain the same they
would remain static they would not go up
or down absent legislative approval
um circling back to what representative
Corman may be asked is that obviously
the current language allows uh inflation
to be a factor in readjusting the system
benefits charge rate with that language
removed again there's no consideration
of other factors like that it would
again be a it would be a legislative
call for policy makers to make
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um
Mr Roberts the the system benefits
charge is a
policy instrument that was invented
decades ago uh and adopted here in New
Hampshire and it's used
by many other states throughout the
country
uh representing an investment a
Strategic investment in Energy
Efficiency as part of the utility
system representative I'm sure there is
a question Roberts knows what the system
benefits charge is yes the point I'm
trying to please ask assistant benefits
charge has been because it's part of the
utility Administration system it like
utility rates has been the province of
Public Utilities commissions which have
staff which conduct all kinds of
economic analyzes of costs and benefits
and carefully adjust rates and the
system benefits charge
wouldn't this bill if adopted be
requiring the fiscal Committee of the
house
uh
of the House of Representatives of New
Hampshire to suddenly acquire all of the
intricate knowledge and economic
analysis ability to properly
evaluate cost benefit
adjust the system benefits charge or not
I mean wouldn't that be a pretty huge
burden to add to the already complicated
work of the house finance committee sure
and thank you for the question I am not
going to uh
legislators can study look at take on
whatever they wish to look at obviously
the legislature decided last year when
it passed uh House Bill 549 that wanted
the more active role in the in where the
system benefits charge levels should be
um obviously with that
um you know they put in an escalator uh
under current language whether or not
the legislature wants to take on more of
a role in determining maybe cost benefit
and that type of thing again obviously a
policy call for folks to make
thank you
thank you further questions from the
committee
representative Summers has another one
just a very quick question Mr chairman
um as with the system benefits charge
though as we know inflation rates can
vary and as they go up would this indeed
increase the cost to the rate payers
uh thank you for the question just to
follow up I guess you're asking as
inflation goes up in the current statute
allows for the consideration of
inflation when the system benefits
charge also increase I think that's what
just that is true yes
thank you
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair
um just to follow up to a question that
I had asked earlier so if I understand
correctly the way this this the way this
bill is worded if it passes the
legislature would
um decide on what the Energy Efficiency
portion of the SBC should be
that would then be fed to either the puc
the doe or the puc I assume to be worked
into the calculation of what the system
benefits charge is I I thank you for the
question so I believe that would likely
be the case
um obviously there is a mechanism in
current statute whereby the system
benefits charge can increase considering
certain factors and then how those
calculations are determined by the
department of energy when it comes to
saying the SBC this bill would remove
that and put the responsibility largely
entirely in the hands of the legislature
to determine what that rate is
follow-up follow-up but my my but my
point is or my question is
it isn't really the res this doesn't
change the responsibility for setting
the entire SBC
to the legislature the the the the
department would still have
responsibility for setting the SBC the
legislature only has responsibility for
setting a portion of the SPC oh God I'm
sorry thank you for the question so I'd
have to take a look through the further
five for uh House Bill 549 statute I've
only got what uh the part of the statute
that's here in House Bill 381 but
obviously as you see on lines
12 to 13 you see that
the Energy Efficiency portion of the
system benefits charge is adjusted based
on various factors as calculated by the
department of energy so that language is
being removed
um and it just it to just replace it
with that the rate will be established
by the New Hampshire general court
so in that aspect I guess the department
of energy is being removed from trying
to help calculate that but again the
legislature at least in this bill is
indicating that would like to take on a
more active role in determining what
that rate should be but if it helps at
all I'd like to take a deeper dive in
the 549 Bill and then follow up with you
by email if that's okay
thank you thank you
representative Randalls you have another
quick question
okay thank you
all right seeing no further questions
for the Department we appreciate thank
you for being here Mr robersh and now I
will call on our consumer Advocate Mr
Don creese
thank you Mr chairman good morning
everybody I'm Donald crease the consumer
Advocate thank you for this opportunity
to testify today about House Bill 381 I
respectfully request that you report
this bill to the floor of the house as
inexpedient to legislate I have four
reasons for making that recommendation
on behalf of the state's residential
ratepayers and I will try to lay each of
them out in elevators speech format
uh although I understand that reasonable
people might differ about weather and to
what extent we should pursue rate
payer-funded Energy Efficiency the state
reached what I thought was a pretty good
consensus on this issue a year ago via
House Bill 549 we should give the
provision of that bill all of the
provisions of that bill time to have
their effect particularly via the
required filing of a new triennial
Energy Efficiency plan this coming
summer
Point number two the Energy Efficiency
portion of the system benefits charge
and the related ldac charge on natural
gas bills are properly regarded as a
regulated rate charged by utilities for
a particular service Energy Efficiency I
respectfully disagree with the notion
that the system benefits charge is a tax
and here is why the SBC is not collected
by the government the money is never in
the hands of the government and not one
cent of the money is spent by the
government
it is I think bad public policy for
legislatures to set utility rates that's
why every state in the country has apuc
or something like it I'm not suggesting
that legislatures particularly this one
lack the skill or the insight to set
rates to the contrary there are enough
phds lawyers and former puc
Commissioners on this committee so that
if you were the puc you'd put any puc in
the country to shame but legislators
lack the time to do full bone rate
investigations and when the puc does it
the decisions have to be based on a full
and fairly developed evidentiary record
based on sworn testimony those are
requirements that are conducive to the
kind of fairness and rigor that I know
you all like to see when it comes to
setting utility rates
uh this uh Point number three responds
to some of the concerns I've heard
already I worry that house bill 381
might 381 might actually be
unconstitutional if the intent here is
to have the puc approve any increases in
the SBC and then subject them to
approval by the general court or the
fiscal committee uh I I think that that
would amount to a one house veto of a
puc decision or even a one committee
veto of a puc decision way back in 1983
in a case entitled ins versus Chata the
U.S Supreme Court decided as a matter of
federal constitutional law that one
house vetoes are unconstitutional the
reason is that they violate the
presentment and bicameralism clauses of
the U.S Constitution
the latter says that Congress can only
act via bills adopted by each chamber
the house and the Senate the former says
that all bills in order to become law
must be presented to the president for
his signature and veto I have no doubt
that the exact same problems would arise
with a one-house veto under the New
Hampshire Constitution as interpreted by
the New Hampshire Supreme Court
finally and this is the most important
thing I have to say at a time when
electricity prices are soaring the very
last thing we want to do is clip the
wings of our rate payer funded NH saves
Energy Efficiency programs to repeat
what I have said In This Very Room just
a few days ago negawatts with an N are
cheaper than megawatts with an M I
respect those who are philosophically
opposed to putting thumbs on the scale
of the market economy and energy to
support Energy Efficiency but to my
friends of that persuasion I say
respectfully please do not let the
perfect become the enemy of the good
that concludes my prepared testimony of
course if it's the chair's pleasure I'd
be happy to answer any questions
thank you Mr Grace we appreciate your
being here and speaking to us about this
bill today I have a question about your
point of constitutionality
because the fiscal committee is a joint
fiscal committee that has both members
of the house and the Senate on it
would that address the question of one
house vetoes
uh I would respectfully suggest it would
not uh simply because neither house in
that scenario meaning neither the Senate
nor the house would actually vote on the
proposal and then pass it along to the
governor for his signature or veto
thank you for your legal opinion on that
question
okay further questions for Mr crease
seeing none I thank you for being here
thank you for letting me off easy and
I'll call to the um call to the front of
the room Mr Michael Licata from
eversource
uh good morning again Michael Licata
representing eversource energy uh coming
before you this time in opposition to HB
381.
um I
won't belabor a number of the points
that have already been made but
our opposition stems from the fact that
this legislation if enacted would really
fundamentally change the uh legislation
that was passed just last year HB 549
which sought to provide consistency to
the utilities and the regulators and our
customers on the funding sources for
Energy Efficiency programs which the
utilities administer on behalf of the
state
um
before uh you know
this section of law that is uh struck
out in the bill
has not been implemented uh yet uh as uh
the consumer Advocate to increase had
mentioned uh we have not yet developed
the next triennial three-year plan that
would be based upon this level of
funding so this would really sort of
put a hard right turn in that process
that was developed under 549 last year
and I would just you know point out that
that legislation was passed unanimously
by both the House and Senate and signed
by the governor uh in an expedited
fashion uh with the intent of providing
that level of consistency and
preservation of the programs
um if this bill were were to move
forward I would Echo the comments of the
Department of energy that
um
additional Clarity uh would be necessary
or welcome uh online 16 through 19
related to exactly how that submission
and approval by either the general court
or the fiscal committee would that be
plans provided by the utilities as is
the case to the Public Utilities
Commission would that process precede
the submission of approval to the fiscal
committee would the Public Utilities
Commission be the The Entity submitting
that approved plan would it be the
department of energy
as you can see there are a lot of
questions uh of uh sort of just process
nature around that
um so with that I will uh be happy to
answer any questions that I can
thank you appreciate your perspective on
this issue questions from the committee
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman I guess I'd kind
of like to resurrect the question that I
was going to ask earlier and just direct
it to you Mr locata it refers to back to
representative Summers question of a
previous Witness
since we've had testimony from you and
from your colleagues at the other
utilities that um
every dollar spent through the system
benefits charge through the New
Hampshire saves program
yields a savings to rate payers of over
four dollars
if that system benefits charge continues
to increase as is contemplated by
current legislation wouldn't the
benefits to rate payers also increase
thank you for the the question
um uh so I think the
the short answer is yes but uh and the
the butt is simply that
um all of the programs uh quite frankly
whether this is passed or whether the
current construct moves forward are
subject to uh astringent and rigorous
cost benefit analysis to achieve the
savings as you describe representative
so
um so even though the the cost of the
program go up
um they still need to meet that that
cost benefit analysis which was
enshrined in uh State Statute with HP
549 called the granite state test
okay thank you
seeing no further questions from the
committee I want to thank you for being
here and we'll call our final
um
individual who would like to speak on
this bill and that is Nick Krakow from
the conservation
conservation law Foundation Nick
welcome
good morning thank you chairman and
committee members
um yeah as he said my name is Nick
Krakow I'm with the conservation law
Foundation here in Concord
um I urge you to oppose HB 381
um and I really question why we're here
today discussing this bill you know as
others have already testified last year
the New Hampshire House and Senate
overwhelmingly passed HB 549
and HP 549 reflected a bipartisan
compromise the Energy Efficiency
programs benefit New Hampshire's economy
Energy Efficiency programs are a
cost-effective way to reduce families
and businesses energy expenditures and
that New Hampshire saves should have a
stable funding level going forward
HP 381 now seeks to undo this careful
bipartisan compromise reflected in HB
by eliminating any adjustments to the
system benefits charge based on the
Consumer Price Index increases
HP 381 would result in reductions in the
funding for New Hampshire State's
programs
because of the high current level of
inflation
these are deductions would likely be
substantial over time
um and this in turn would likely to
translate to less funding for
cost-effective and popular Energy
Efficiency programs
and
probably loss of Energy Efficiency jobs
HP 549 reflects
a rare bipartisan win for New Hampshire
um and I urge the committee to vote
against this bill and vote itl and I'm
happy to answer any questions this time
thank you
thank you questions for Mr krakov
seeing none I thank you for your
testimony
and I have no additional pink cards for
this bill is there anyone in the
audience who would like to speak who has
not spoken apparently there is one
person
please come forward sir
please hand your pink card to miss
Thomas over here thank you
thank you representative
and so I'm about to introduce
Mr Ken Grant who is a citizen of
Barrington New Hampshire welcome Mr Kim
Grant thank you I'll make this quick uh
not experience the public speaking I
I've received bills from uh eversource
for my property which is 1100 square
foot property would I keep the
thermostat at 70 degrees uh yet in the
bill that I've received I have become
suspect of emitting greenhouse gases and
I
I'm then not having any solar or any any
energy alternatives to receive this
transfer payment of this uh Energy
Credit the system benefit charge but in
in my opinion it's more than a tax it's
a payment a transfer charge and yet uh
people there are houses that are two
three times the size of my house that
might be receiving this benefit charge
but they've got things like to a couple
air conditioners there there are three
or four thousand square foot houses they
may even have more than one uh oil or
fuel heating source and I just don't I
uh see why that
I'm being charged uh uh this type of tax
for this payment transfer to subsidize
somebody somebody else and
um
there must be a cost there must be some
type of administration cost to this that
I'm also paying for and that uh I I
oppose the system benefit charge if
people want all this stuff uh they
should be willing to pay for it but
than coming taxing me for it I don't
agree with I I support the build up
thank you
okay well thank you very much for your
testimony
seeing no questions for Mr Grant
I will close the public hearing
on House Bill 381 and ask Mr closure
representative closure to tell us what
the blue sheet has to say about it
uh thank you chair
House Bill 381
there was two in favor
um
I pardon
there was two opposed none in favor I do
not have the online information great
thank you very much
okay we're still about a half hour
behind
given our schedule here this morning but
I am going to call for a five minute
recess
so that we can have a bio break and then
we will return to this room to take up
house bill 385. recess for five minutes
thank you
facilities
all right
yesterday
people tell me
thank you
and then I don't know
good morning how are you
um
okay
thank you
yeah
I know it's like someone without me oh
yes
yeah
let's see yeah
it's another yeah
thank you
welcome
songs
30-second warning for starting the next
bill
and I count fast I'm going to open up
Bill 385 with representative chairman
Vose introducing his bill
thank you Mr Vice chair and good morning
to the members of the committee once
again
with the record I'm representative
Michael Bose I represent Rockingham five
District Five the town of Epping and I
serve as chair of this committee
so I'm here this time to introduce House
Bill 385
which is a bill that the Public
Utilities Commission asked me to file
when the Public Utilities Commission
was separated into a smaller puc and a
big department of energy
there were a lot of administrative
strings to untangle
to separate the two entities
and one of the strings that needed to be
Unwound
involved giving Authority from that was
previously with the puc to the doe and
vice versa
foreign
this bill
arose from the realization by the puc
that
complaints that might arise from newly
passed legislation on computer Community
aggregation
should probably better be resolved by
the department rather than the
commission
unless there was a disagreement between
the complainant and the department in
which case the commission
would become the Arbiter the adjudicator
of a final decision
so this bill was submitted to transfer
that Authority from the commission
which previously had jurisdiction over
RSA 53e Community power aggregation
to the Department of energy for
complaint investigation
that is the uh
basically the
the purpose of the bill that's all the
language that the bill does
and
there are people behind me who I'm sure
will testify to give you more detail on
why this was necessary
whether or not it will cost
or has costs that the department of
energy would have to assume
and whether they can afford to assume
that without
um
an appropriation being added to the bill
all of that will be revealed in
subsequent testimony to mine so I'm
going to end it there and open
the Florida questions and the people who
want to testify behind me thank you
thank you representative Rose for the
explanation I'll call on representative
Summers for a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
chairman quick question for you
um would the would current
um stated statutes with a puc still be
able to receive complaints at the puc
if we pass this would that yes I'm sorry
yes yes
no I think that the the complaints would
go to the Department of energy they
would try to resolve the complaint
according to the language of the bill
if they could not satisfy the
complainant
adequately the complaint had objected to
whatever
solution that the department came up
with then they could appeal that
decision to the commission
thank you
representative Wendy Thomas
thank you um
I'm not sure what the problem is that
this bill is trying to fix so can you
answer I had the puc objected to having
to resolve complaints
the p2c is a much smaller organization
now than it used to used to be it only
has as you will call from the
presentation we heard last Friday it
only has 16
employee full-time employees and maybe a
couple of part-time employees
so they have far less staff to deal with
issues such as this than they used to
the department of energy on the other
hand has like 75 or 80 employees they
have a compliance division which is
charged with dealing with complaints and
other compliance issues so the
commission felt that this responsibility
more properly lay with the Department of
energy
thank you
uh thank you thank you for taking my
question would it be correct am I
correct in stating that the consumer
group that used to work for the puc has
the Personnel the responsibilities that
has moved over the department of energy
I believe that is correct you could
verify that with the spokesman for the
Department of energy
representative munz
thank you Mr chair
um I I'm I'm
struggling with the um the the the the
the flow here
um the you know if if somebody has you
know the way I read this is the
commission sets the rules
or makes the initial ruling then if the
if the if the individual has an issue
they go to the DOE
uh the doe decides but if that if the
person involved in that decision still
has an issue it goes back to the
commission so the same people
that are setting the rules get the
ultimate decision on what the resolution
would be
why wouldn't the why wouldn't the
initial
um complaint be handled by the puc with
the doe being kind of the final
arbitrator to kind of negotiate a
settlement
good question thank you representative
for it the issue here is investigating
the complaint
the POC doesn't have the resources to
investigate the complaint whereas the
due and its compliance division
hopefully does they may require some
additional resources we'll hear about
that
in subsequent testimony but
presumably because they have a much
larger staff they're in a better place
to do complaint investigation then the
commission is itself the commission
itself can
make you know adjudicate issues of
dispute
once the facts are known once the
investigation is complete but they don't
have
or at least they're telling us through
this legislation that they don't have
the staff to do the investigation
follow-up
uh one follow-up okay uh
isn't the issue that wouldn't the issue
therefore be
the allocation of staff that perhaps
some of the staff that was
sent from the puc to the doe needs to go
back to the puc
foreign
I can't comment on that if anybody from
the commission testifies at this uh
public hearing you could ask them that
question
thank you thank you uh we're starting to
have circular questions here so I think
I'd like to move on thank you
representative Rose for your testimony I
like to call on Mr
Griffin Roberge from the Department of
energy who I'm sure has heard a lot of
questions that he can answer
foreign
thank you uh chairman Thomas members of
the committee Griffin Roberts again from
the Department of energy
um the department is neutral on this
bill
um for context uh The Spill amends State
Statute
um uh regarding complaints arising from
Community electric aggregation plans
under current statute the public utility
vets and approves Community aggregation
plans under administrative rule the puc
currently vets complaints but none of
these Community aggregation plans have
really gone live as of yet so the puc
has not received any com active
complaints right now
HB 385 outlines a process to sell
complaints arising from municipal or
County aggregation committees the
community power aggregator or the
utility before the department of energy
per the bills process a complaint is
submitted to the department and is
shared with all parties doe May issue an
order requiring the complaint complaint
to be addressed or the complaint be
addressed by the complaint about party
doe is allowed to investigate complaints
and we may bring proceedings before the
puc or if the complaintant is
unsatisfied with our the Department's
findings they may obviously appeal as
has been mentioned to the puc do we
wanted to note several observations
should this bill move forward in its
current form the department does not
have an appropriate Revenue stream to
build this new regulatory responsibility
while the department normally uses
utility assessments to pay for its work
on dealing with electric distribution
companies there is no means currently in
state statute for doe to place an
assessment on municipalities and
Community aggregation plans
additionally there is nothing in State
Statute that gives doe the authority to
compel these Community aggregations or
utilities to undertake any specific
action in the complaint do we obviously
under this language can issue findings
and issue orders but it doesn't have any
um enforcement mechanisms to compel
parties to engage in any type of
activity or remedy
additionally goe cannot predict how
frequently complaints will occur or how
many complaints the department will
receive over any given period of time
should these complaints be made
frequently as I mentioned it's likely we
will not have the Staffing Resources to
vet these complaints we expect that the
complaints will likely be very complex
and time consuming
um we are estimating that we will likely
need back of the envelope figures likely
need two additional positions full-time
attorney and a full-time utility analyst
to process these complaints I know that
uh when we're the prime sponsor
testified that
um there's some discussion about the
allocation of resources between the puc
and the doe it is true that a lot of the
consumer division staff that was
formerly at the puc have now been rolled
over to the Department of energy if the
thought was to have the consumer
division within the department of energy
take these on again
um they do not have the current
resources to vet these complaints um
there would likely need to be the
additional positions funded and for
additional context we've heard that the
puc is a very slim regulatory body
operating solely on for adjudication
issues regardless of whether or not
these complaints remain with the puc or
are shifted over to the department a lot
of these concerns will remain whether or
not the puc or doe have the resources to
vet these complaints whether or not the
puc or the doe have the um
have the appropriate revenue streams to
bill for this type of work so these are
all things we want the committee to
consider should they move forward with
this bill
um and with that I'm happy to answer any
questions
thank you Mr Royers Rovers I'll have a
I'll ask my question here to you based
on what you just said
for clarification it sounds like
neither the doe nor the puc
are ready or equipped to assume any
complaints from the community
aggregation program once it gets going
is is that is that what you're saying so
thank you for the question so there is
currently a process under administrative
role at the puc to vet complaints
however I think a lot of the issues
regarding Revenue stream and Staffing
frequency of when these of how often
these complaints may occur are things
that things to consider off in the
future once these complaints start
arising they haven't Arisen yet so it is
something for policy makers to consider
obviously Community aggregation was a
result of House Bill 315 two years ago
it was a substantial policy change there
are obviously pieces that still need to
be flushed down and picked up after that
thank you representative Winnie Thomas
thank you um
I understand you can't give us a number
of anticipated complaints but surely you
can give us a number of complaints that
have already happened so do you have an
estimate of how often these complaints
happen is it yearly is it monthly sure
uh thank you for the question so
um as I mentioned the puc approves
Community aggregation plans to ensure
that they're in conformance with State
Statute and administrative rule but it's
my understanding is that none of these
Community aggregation plans have
actually taken off as of yet like none
are live they've gotten approval but
they still need to they still need to
develop so in that instance I believe
that there have been no active
complaints made before the puc as of yet
so I couldn't give any type of
indication as to what might come up in
the future but something for
policymakers to consider
representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman quick question
when we had puc testified in front of us
last week and we brought up the the fact
that they have a stated order that says
that the utilities can only go to the
market once every six months to buy
electricity and they said they were
investigating it because of the size of
their body right now who would be
investigating it right now and if this
bill was passed would that
responsibility fall upon the DOE
thank you for the question so I wasn't
here for the puc's presentation so I'll
take your word about what they mentioned
about uh utilities seeking default
service
if they I imagine I imagine they have
enough I believe they have a number of
Investigations pending right now those
investigations are largely done
um by the three Commissioners by the by
the Public Utilities Commission itself
with assistance from their staff
um
whether or not those investigations
might impact their ability to vet these
complaints I don't know that's a that's
a work load issue that might be better
directed at the puc
thank you representative partial
chair and thank you for being here today
um
this seems like a preemptive solution to
something that we really don't know if
it's going to be a problem yet and I
applaud the idea of trying to be
preemptive and before problem occurs uh
but at the same time could you say this
is uh because we don't know the scope of
the problem yet could you say this is a
solution looking for a problem uh
thank you for the thank you for the
question representative
um I don't know if I would necessarily
say that I think I would I would say
that
um I think I've turned it around a
little bit and say this is I guess maybe
a hole in the regulatory process uh
around these Community aggregation plans
it's not necessarily a hole that's
presenting a problem yet but it might be
something for policy makers to consider
as these Community aggregation plans
start getting up and off the ground and
becoming live and active
representative Nutter
thank you Mr chair could Community power
vendors pay for complaint investigations
uh thank you for the question
um
it's possible but under the I I guess I
could say yeah it's possible but under
the current language that's not
something that's uh that's indicated
here
or it's not an option I guess in the
current language I should say
representative Corman thank you Mr chair
and thank you once again for taking my
question
can you describe what the nature of a
complaint might be I know this is
speculative but I'm just wondering you
know what what would these complaints be
like sure uh thank you for the question
I I couldn't give you too much of detail
on that as of yet but under the current
language this process only arises if a
complaint comes from a municipal or
County aggregator or an electric
distribution utility it is my
understanding let's say if you're just a
resident in a municipality with a
community aggregation your complaint
would not go through this plot process
you would then you would first complain
to the town it's kind of like a kind of
like uh dealing with a water district or
your water bill right you go to your
local water district you don't appeal
straight up to the puc or the Supreme
Court about it
um
regarding I guess the nature of the
complaints as to what they might entail
I don't know but
um
I would submit that I you know elect uh
Community aggregation plans are fairly
complex they're not necessarily A
straightforward thing
um so I do imagine that it will take uh
some staff time to vet these complaints
into and to conduct a full investigation
and everything like that
thank you I censor questions are
circling around the same subject matter
uh I'd like to move on now thank you for
your testimony thank you I'm going to
call on
a subject matter expert on this which
would be Mr Clifton below who has
promised me he will solve all of your
questions
thank you Mr chairman
um
let's see
um we don't I'm here on behalf of the
community power Coalition in New
Hampshire a joint power agency comprised
of 28 subdivisions of the state
um 27 municipalities in one County that
are looking to launch community power
aggregation programs some as early as
April of this year
um we don't have a position of
particularly for or against this bill I
certainly understand that the puc is got
a limited Staffing
um in general uh there is language and
statute along these lines or or in rules
uh that deal with how
um
it used to be the puc but it was shifted
in in the reorganization to the
Department of energy how they deal with
complaints and I don't think this is
limited to complaints uh
made by Community aggregations or the
utility but it is limited if you look on
line 17 it says complaints pertaining to
actions undertaken omitted by any
municipal or County aggregator or
electric distribution utility arising
under this chapter shall be made to the
department so that that goes on
currently although this is not addressed
per se in law the rules that the puc
adopted do provide that the complaints
would go to the puc and they would
follow similar steps
um I do you know if the bill moves
forward I do have a few suggestions that
I think would address some concerns that
we have
um and I'll just say
um
we we do have some issues uh where we
feel that the utilities are not acting
in compliance with the rules that have
been adopted at this point we are
working directly with the utilities to
try to resolve those and to help help
them come into compliance some of it's
just because this is new and it takes a
while to implement certain things and
some things haven't been implemented yet
that that the rules call for so you know
we we don't want to make any formal
complaints but um it's at some point we
may need to uh because it you know we
are letting the utilities know that at
this point well with at least two of
them uh that some of the delays and
complaints with the rules are risking uh
delay in our ability to launch
um that being said I think my concern
are that when complaints well there's
two kinds of complaints I should say the
consumer affairs division uh which was
part of the puc and was moved over to
doe traditionally handled just like a
res residential rate payer that would
have you know a complaint that their
bill wasn't calculated right or
something like that and those would not
be publicly docketed the the consumer
affairs would work with customer and the
utility to try to resolve it and the
vast majority of those would be resolved
occasionally they'd get escalated to an
adjudicated proceeding at the commission
and the commission would have to decide
the matter
um but um traditionally uh if a business
of something other than a residential
rate payer made a complaint it would get
docketed and so there'd be a public
record of it and so this is one of my
first concerns um just using an example
might a private business that I'm a
partner in one Court Street Associates
filed a complaint in May of 2017
regarding it was complaint against
Liberty utility for them failing to
maintain certain of their distribution
facilities
um they responded to the complaint we
replied to that in June of 2017
um asking for an independent
investigation because we didn't think
their response was satisfactory a
technical session was scheduled in
January of 2018
and held
and then sort of nothing happened in the
docket for a number of years
um
and finally on uh
just about a year ago in February of
2022 the puc issued a order seeking a
status report from the Department of
energy uh since in on July 2021 they
were made responsible for conducting
these investigations uh into consumer
complaints
um
and they asked the question you know
what's the status of the investigation
and should we close this docket and the
department of energy replied
um uh on the deadline of March 9 2022
and said the department has not
completed its investigation into this
matter and has not yet concluded whether
filing
or they're filing a motion to bring the
complaint before the commission is
warranted
so nothing has happened since then
there's no record of the complaint
that's publicly visible on the
department of energy website they they
have not unlike the puc they don't
docket complaints like this so one of my
requests would be that for
non-residential rate payers that the com
that the department of energy publicly
docket the complaint and put the
complaint in the utility response in a
publicly available location through
their website because there may be other
entities that have a similar concern and
this could certainly apply to either
Community power aggregations or
utilities where there's a a complaint I
think residential is different because
maybe residential people don't want that
information public they'd rather just
try to resolve the problem so that's one
suggestion
um two other suggestions are um
uh allowing
um complaints that are made before the
effective date of the law uh to go ahead
and proceed and follow the existing
process so so my concern for instance
with this other complaint is it was at
the puc for a number of years
um
transferred to doe there's no
you know it's not clear if we had to
start all over again or not and that
might be the case
um so one thing to do another thing that
could be done is it says effective 60
days after passage it was it was made
effective upon passage then you'd sooner
know who this should be going to the
Department of energy rather than the POC
but if something gets filed
um in the next month or two with the POC
I would hope that it could just proceed
through that process and that would be
consistent with the idea of not making
laws retroactive
um
and so my final suggestion would be uh
that there might be a time limit on
review by the department that
um if if they haven't
um come up with a uh
a recommendation a resolution of the
matter within 180 days you know six
months that the complainant whether it's
the utility against the committee
congregation or vice versa or an
individual that the complaintant should
be able to after some period of time say
six months uh if they want escalate it
to to request an adjudicating proceeding
at the commission so it just doesn't
linger forever and there's just no
deadline for anyone to take any action
so those are my suggestions you know I
think overall it's it's reasonable uh
because the idea is the Department of
energy has more of the staff to do this
uh but but that's um you know those are
my thoughts thank you thank you very
much
I see um representative partial as a
question
yes thank you chair and thank you for
your uh
Illuminating testimony is your testimony
written no
um it's just
nope it was just spontaneous
sure I could I would love to see you
examine these recommendations to make a
little bit closer though could we
get to them I I was taking notes but I
I'd be happy we're not engaging in a in
a discussion here the subject matter is
whether or not the the merits of the
bill is to be uh is to complaints to be
transferred to the uh you know doe uh so
they stand corrected representative
months thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in again do you have any
concerns about a process where if you
have a complaint
that complaint gets handled by a third
party
that third party makes a decision
and then but then the appeal the only
rights of appeal that you would have if
you disagree with that is to go back to
the original party that you originally
had a pro a concern with
and I guess I'm coming back to the
question I had asked earlier about you
know shouldn't the role of the doe be to
be kind of a neutral arbitrator to kind
of figure out you know what the right
course of action is between the position
that the complaintant takes and the
composition that the puc has taken
uh well it's not really about a position
the puc has taken they have adopted
rules
um which is essentially an extension of
the legislative function to flesh out
the details of how the chapter should
work
um
you know structurally it's the puc
that's supposed to be the arbitrator of
the the balances the interest of
uh rate pairs Community power
aggregations utilities
um by various criteria uh
so I I think
sort of a generic concern is that we
don't sort of create two regulatory
authorities that the doe becomes a
regulator
in addition to the puc
um but it does make sense that the staff
that used to be part of the puc that
would do the investigation and perhaps
make a recommendation try to resolve the
matter without litigation so to speak uh
that those staff have been over moved
over to the doe so I so I understand the
logic of having doe staff try to uh you
know investigate and you know seek a
resolution
um but if it's if they're going to have
to make sort of judgments or start
ordering uh somebody to do something
that's the role of the puc they're the
ones who have plenary authority over the
utilities and can direct them to do
something or not
um
and yeah so that's a thought follow-up
yeah one quick follow-up please
uh if that being the case I mean just by
the fact that we are inserting the doe
into the process
we are kind of violating that principle
that you've stated that this the puc's
responsibility
wouldn't the better approach be to move
the staff into the puc
well they were just that's a legislative
decision and and the decision was to
move them to the doe in general all
complaints that would regard going to
utilities or competitive electric power
suppliers now would go to the doe and
they could be escalated to the puc
um if the party's not satisfied with the
resolution I was just suggesting that
that that be an option after some period
of time so it just doesn't linger
forever
yeah I I think we need to to uh ask
questions involving the actual Merit of
the Bill of going from the puc to the
doe we've heard a lot of questions that
are becoming very similar now about
Staffing uh I will take one more
question if it pertains to the mechanics
or technical issue of this bill in terms
of getting better Clarity on it
representative Harrington
uh thank you and thank you for taking my
question in your experience at the
commission what would you say the
percentage of complaints that have to go
up to commission review or as compared
to most of them being done at the lower
level
um just a tiny fraction I I wouldn't
know the number but during my 10 years
of commissioner you probably can reflect
on this too there was just a handful uh
yeah two or three maybe I can recall a
couple or three maybe
um yeah and I would just say I can't
imagine this would take a full even a
single full-time position I I there
might be
a few occasional complaints certainly
municipalities that are going to be very
concerned about being responsive to
their citizens so we're being very
conscious about about making sure our
aggregations are complying with the
rules in the law and if if there's an
issue I I would expect that we would
resolve it rather quickly
thank you I think we've heard enough
questions involving this bill here
they're all becoming very similar thank
you so much for your testimony I don't
see any other pink cards here therefore
uh I will declare this
public hearing closed
and ask representative poche to read the
blue sheet
thank you chair
House Bill 385
the blue sheet there was none in support
none opposed
online
there was one in support two opposed
and Mr chair Mr materials yes if you
like I do have the online to report for
House Bill 381 okay please read it
House Bill
381 relative to the system benefit
charge the previous bill
the blue sheet was again
zero and support to oppose online was
one in support 45 a pulse thank you
chair
okay thank you
moving right along trying to catch up
with our schedule I'm going to open a
public hearing on House Bill 251 and
call on the bills Prime sponsor
Vice chair of this committee
representative Douglas Thomas
thank you Mr chair and thank you to the
committee uh for giving me the
opportunity to brief on HB 251.
um I'm not going to go into a lot of
history because it'll take too long but
basically uh about three years ago the
house and the Senate with the governor's
approval uh decided that it was in the
best interests of our residential
customers to know what they're what
they're paying for on their on their
electric bill and so we decided that it
would be a good practice for
transparency to have the
estimated annual cost of the RPS
portion of the bill be displayed on
their electric bill and it was decided
that December would be the time period
that that it would display this annual
amount
when it got to the Senate they they
agreed but they decided that the amount
to be shown would be based on the
kilowatt hour basis
I'm not sure exactly what that meant to
this day uh even now my electric bill
does not show the cost of RPS in those
words and
um and I I get the sense that no other
customer would have any idea
how this law was put into effect but it
is my feeling that since we've already
decided that it's important enough to
show the cost of the RPS program on your
electric bill
annualized that we should change the the
law that said it should be done in terms
of total dollars so that people can
understand what they're seeing
and I've
looked at my December bill and
there is no word that says RPS on there
there is
s there's the SBC charges but I don't
see any word on here that explains how
much money was spent on on RPS or charge
to me anyway so I I have a concern that
maybe possibly an amendment might be in
order if this is not already being shown
on my electric bill but I would like to
hear comments from anyone behind me that
that can explain that process but again
the thrust of this bill is is to merely
change the measurement factor from a
kilowatt basis to just total dollars so
people can understand what they're
seeing on this bill and that's the basis
of of my bill uh any other questions I
think I would like to defer to uh either
uh the utilities behind me or anyone
else because uh I I cannot answer why
it's not showing on my bill
just for clarification though to make
sure I understand what you're trying to
do here
rather than have the bill show
the cost of RPS compliance as being 0.0
three seven cents per kilowatt hour
you want the bill to show our cost for
RPS and client compliance was 57 for the
year is that correct that's correct that
was the intent of the bill but I don't
even see that on my electric bill for
December so I have questions about where
if a word
.0037 cents per kilowatt hour I don't
even see that on my bill so I I have
questions on that as well
okay uh representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Thomas Doug Thomas for
taking my question what would you think
about just having both the per kilowatt
hour and the total annual cost showing
on the bill I have the objection to both
I have concerns that I don't see either
representative Noel has a question
taking my question is the total cost
you're talking about the total cost uh
accumulated over the course of the
previous year or is it total cost of the
RPS program
uh it would be an estimated cost
and uh
yeah and as I I didn't make any changes
it would say for the prior compliance
here okay I missed that as it is yeah
thank you
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um when we get into the cost here is
this a average per you know we have the
Standard customer out there that's 650
megawatt uh 650 kilowatt hours per month
or is this the actual cost to that
customer so if you used uh a lot more
than the average person your bill would
show a much higher charge if you used a
lot less you'd show a lower charge or is
it some kind of an average
well it's my understanding uh obviously
if you use more kilowatt hours you
you'll get a higher charge on there but
the cost alone is an estimate because
after all they have to do a lot of
compilation not in time to cover for the
December bill but again as the as the
law as the uh the untouched portion of
the bill says is from the prior
compliance year and again we were told
in testimony a couple years ago that it
would be an estimate anyway it's always
an estimate not exactly to to the penny
but close enough to know what you're
spending a follow-up
follow up so I'm just trying to get this
straight so let's just say in the course
of a year I use uh 6 000 kilowatt hours
with the estimate base be based on what
the charge was per kilowatt hour basis
is the present law says times that 6 000
and that's what would appear on my bill
or would it be the average customer uses
this much electricity in the course of a
year so for an average customer this is
the cost
is my understanding that it would be
based on your usage not on any average
all right thank you
additional questions representative
Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chair
um
as I think about
the
um
what you're trying to achieve here with
the utilities calculating and then
disclosing to each consumer each each
rate payer the cost of their RPS
compliance for their total Supply and
then divided by all their customers
in their in their territory
I'm thinking that the maybe the reason
the utilities haven't gotten there in
terms of disclosing anything on the bill
is that it seems like it would be really
uh complicated have do the utilities
have you talked to the utilities about
this bill or do they have a position on
like their ability we heard concern
earlier about the you know the costs of
administering the billing process
um have have you talked to the utilities
about how much how easy or how difficult
this would be to do for every consumer
bill
well thank you for the question and uh
three or so years ago when uh correct me
if I'm wrong I think representative Rose
might have been the prime sponsor on the
original bill but my memory escapes me a
bit but I was there and and we had that
very discussion at that time and uh I
believe the utilities uh although
expressed a little bit of concern on how
they would do it they had no objection
to it uh the fact that the house and the
Senate and the governor has signed this
into law would tell me that the
utilities would would need to comply
with it admit it okay thank you
as a point of information I am looking
at my December
20 2022 bill
and under
a heading called important information
my bill reads as follows
the 2021 average Statewide renewable
portfolio standard compliance cost was
dollars
0.0051 per kilowatt hour
information on the RPS including its
benefits may be found on the New
Hampshire Department of Energy's website
and then it lists the
the URL for the website
so my bill does disclose this is the New
Hampshire Electric Co-op that that
serves my uh my distribution area my
bill does disclose
that information but only as a per
kilowatt hour choice or charge
so it's not clear to me from the way
it's worded whether that's
if that
zero zero fifty one
Cent per kilowatt hour charge is
based on my usage or is just general
usage it's not clear
so that's a point of information
representative Reynolds has another
question well it I guess it'd be I don't
know if it's may I ask a question back
to you sir
um sure if
the
most utility bills show
a customer's
12 past you know 12 months usage so
isn't the intent there it sounds like a
customer if they wanted to know what
their total cost to them of RPS
compliance would be to look at their
12-month kilowatt hour usage and just do
the math 650 kilowatt hours times that
per kilowatt you know I'm saying the
average number but each customer could
say if I use double the average use up I
used you know 1200 kilowatt hours a
month I would then use 100
fourteen thousand four hundred kilo
hours a year times the figure you cited
and they would get their cost of
compliance
yes and I will do that math for you
really quickly all right
so I used 565 kilowatt hours that month
that month I'll multiply that times
.0051
and that comes out to
2.88
if I did that math correctly yeah I
think he might have I think he didn't
have enough decimal places I think
possible I multiplied it by
anyway we'll take this offline this
calculation but you're right that's how
it could be done but what I think
representative Thomas and this bill is
suggesting that why should a customer
have to make that computation when the
utility could do it and put the total
amount on the bill
that would be more transparent
and would help people understand exactly
what they're paying for
so
any further questions on this uh
legislation we have one more person who
would like to testify so
let's move on and representative Corman
has a question so I just downloaded my
bill from Liberty and I'm in the same
boat as you representative Thomas
there's nothing about this charge on my
bill
no dude
okay so noted all right thank you
representative Thomas for introducing
this bill I'll Now call on Griffin
Robbers from the Department of energy
for the Department's perspective
foreign
Thomas don't forget to submit a pink
card
uh thank you chairman votes members of
the committee Griffin Roberge again from
the New Hampshire Department of energy
um no surprise we're neutral on this
bill as introduced
um for context just because it's been
mentioned frequently here at this
statute uh that's subject to House Bill
251 was created by House Bill 1550 and
2018. the statute requires the estimated
cost of the RPS on a per kilowatt hour
basis to be displayed on an electric
customer's December bill
this estimated cost will be focused on
the prior RPS compliance year this
estimation is done once a year and
information about the RPS including its
benefits is available via a link to the
appropriate State website utilities are
allowed to recover the costs of
providing this information from Electric
rate payers on their bill
um House Bill 1550 as uh as has been
mentioned here uh simply just requires
the per kilowatt hour usage to be posted
on an electric customer's December bill
that rate is an average that has arrived
at every year for the prior compliance
year so uh
referencing what you mentioned uh
chairman Vos every year in the renewable
energy fund report that the department
puts out we list out the costs of our PS
for the RPS compliance as we all know
the RPS uh for electric providers to
satisfy that must either purchase Rex
and acps those come at a cost
um based on
information that representative uh
mentioned as well as available on the
report the average per kilowatt rate
impact for RPS compliance was .0051
dollar cents
um you would then take that rate
multiply it against your respective
usage and you would arrive at your RPS
compliance cost for that month
um or you could gather all your 12
months worth of bills put them together
and then you know figure out what your
cost is per year so assuming a 650
kilowatt monthly consumption that's an
average electric customer's consumption
every year I'm sorry averaging that
number against the compliance year 21
RPS cost
that would be about 3.31 cents a month
or 39.78 a year
circling back to the bill the the bill
before you House Bill 1251 I mean uh 251
the bill proposes to remove the per
kilowatt information that's provided on
a customer's Bill and instead would be
required to show the estimated total
cost in dollars for compliance with the
RPS for the prior compliance year and
hearing the prime sponsor's testimony I
believe the focus is to have the
individualized cost in dollars shown on
electric customers Bill respectfully
that is not how the department views the
bill as currently written we view it as
demonstrating the overall fat cost of
RPS compliance being posted on a
customer's bill so last year for
compliance year 21 the average cost for
the art the total RPS compliance cost
was about 53 million dollars that is the
figure that would be posted on folks
December bill and in hearing the product
sponsors testimony that is not what's
indicated that's not what's wanted I
believe
um if the goal is to provide an
estimated cost in dollars for each
respective Electric customer I imagine
that will require some type of billing
modification from the utilities
which those cost per the language on
lines 12 to 4 12 to 13 will likely be
recovered from Electric customers
um with that I'm happy to take any
questions that folks might have
thank you Mr Roberts for refreshing my
memory about house bill 1550.
I remember now some of the details about
the debate on that bill before it was
passed in fact it went to
it it passed the house
um
describing the cost in the way that
representative Thomas Doug Thomas
suggests that it should in this bill
and the bill actually went to a
committee of conference and it was in
the committee of conference that Senator
Bradley insisted that it be changed to
the per kilowatt hour average rather
than the total average
but I am recalling now that when we
discussed with the utilities whether
they could calculate it out for every
individual customer they indicated that
that would be very costly
so the bill as it was eventually signed
by the governor just required that the
average costs be placed on the bill
so
as I just read my bill a few minutes ago
instead of it being
0.0051 dollars per kilowatt hour
as you pointed out a 650 kilowatt hour
customer would be paying about 39 a year
a year yes that's the number that should
be on the bill according to
representative Thomas's bill is I
understand it
is that your understanding
um and here uh thank you for the
question so in hearing you explain that
I do understand it now
um
yeah I can't speak for utilities on
their ability to post that information
uh easily on their bill obviously
there's limited space on bills and any
type of change on the type of
information that they need to put on a
bill will likely require some type of uh
Billing System modification that again
is recovered from electricity electric
customers
um but that's what I in hearing the
discussion here today that's what we
believe the intention to be in looking
at the language as it's currently
drafted in the bill we view it as
utilities are posting the total cost in
dollars of RPS for the prior compliance
year it's not individualized in any any
way shape or form is the total fat cost
of RPS compliance that all ratepayers
paid so again for compliance year 21
that figure was around I think 53
million dollars that would be the figure
that would be put on the bill based on
our read
before this public hearing
okay thank you representative Corman has
a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you once
again Mr Roberts so if I understand
correctly then you would support an
amendment that just makes it clear that
this uh amount of this estimated total
cost should be either per customer or
for the individual customer rather than
the entire RPS across the entire State
sure and thank you for the question we
are neutral on the bill we'd likely be
neutral with any type of change but I
think I would respectfully suggest that
um to determine maybe whether or not the
utilities are able to accommodate this
that the committee and or the sponsors
of the bill may want to reach out to the
utilities to inquire with them about
this proposed change and whether they'd
be able to uh undertake it
thank you if my utility can put the 0 0
51 dollar amount on the bill
then they could easily put the
650 kilowatt per month average total of
39 and whatever you said it was yep it
could easily put that on the bill
so do we have any further questions for
Mr Roberts representative Reynolds has a
question
thank you Mr chairman
um
since the administration of the utility
the public utility system and the
utility rate making process is all about
balancing costs and benefits
what would you think of the
um an amendment to this bill that would
require the calculation and the
placement on each customer's bill of
an amount that represents the benefits
of the RPS policy thank you for the
question so I uh I would
submit that might be difficult to
quantify that at least for the
Department we don't have any you know
year-to-year independent economic
analysis for the benefit that the RPS
has on an individual's specific electric
rates
um
was it I I would reference
um the committee to line 11 where it
does require
um on a customer's Bill to not only
identify the cost but also provide a
link to the information about the RPS
including its benefits at uh the State
website so obviously folks can go there
to see it but
um you know at least from the
Department's perspective I think it'd be
at least difficult for us to arrive at a
specific figure for the benefits of the
RPS
follow-up before you follow up I just
want to point out that having been
intimately involved in House Bill 1550
back in 2018 or whenever it was that was
a compromise that was arrived at by all
parties that putting a link to the RPS
information on
at that time the puc website was the
solution to the to the question that you
just asked okay
okay thank you now you can follow up if
you need to
well you know I guess I would I would
add I would
ask you about we we've had presentations
from each utility
um
in the early part of our session here uh
year
um
in particular the the uh
grid operator showed us that the
presence of distributed generation
renewable you know per the renewable
portfolio standard you know lowered
wholesale power costs by X and simply
dividing that large
reduction in wholesale power costs
across the rate base could provide
a figure in the same way that
this figure cost of RPS compliance is is
being arrived at
what do you think do you think is that
analogous uh I I guess thank you for the
question
um you know whether or not policymakers
want to put on some specific figure to
show a numerical benefit of the RPS on a
customer's bill is obviously their call
I can only just reference what's you
know typically put out every year by the
department and its renewable energy fund
report obviously the costs are
relatively easy to quantify trying to
quantify year to year the benefits of of
um quantify the benefits every year
might be a little bit bigger of an
economic undertaking and Beyond at least
the resources of our staff to quantify
obviously if there's some other type of
resource that
legislators think should be shown on a
bill to show that numerical benefit
that's obviously their call
thank you okay further questions for Mr
Roberge
seeing none I want to thank you for
thank you coming to give us the
Department's perspective on this
legislation I have no more pink cards
for this bill is there anyone sitting in
the audience who would like to speak on
this bill who has not spoken so far
seeing none I will close the public
hearing on House Bill 251 and ask Mr
representative closet to give us the
blue sheet
Cali thank you chair I'll spill two five
one
the blue sheet zero in support one
oppose online one in support 52 oppose
thank you
so we actually caught up
amazing I'm I'm I'm
encouraged that our experiment may have
proved to be productive that we were
able to get through four bills
and instead of using three hours
or instead of using an hour per bill
we only used about 45 minutes per bill
which is pretty good now that
could just be because of the nature of
the bills I don't know but
um it was an encouraging experiment in
any case
yeah we'll take a win whenever we can
get one right so
um
we're going to take a lunch break now
and it's going to be actually a little
bit longer a lunch break than I
anticipated I anticipated we would go
all the way to noon before we took that
break
so we're not due back here until 1 30 at
which time we will have an executive
session
on four five bills including two bills
that we had an executive session on last
Friday
House Bill 211 and House Bill 633 both
of those bills the minority leader and I
agreed
we could exec on the same day that we
heard those bills
but we both had forgotten that we had
scheduled the exact session on those
bills for today
so I called the house Clerk and said hey
we already did those is that okay and he
said no that's not okay he said you can
have an exact session on a bill
after it's been noticed but you can't
have one before it's been noticed so
we're going to have to redo House Bill
211 and House Bill 633 hopefully that'll
take five minutes each bill and then we
can move on to the exact sessions for
House Bill 139 House Bill 166 and House
Bill 219 FN
so that is our schedule for this
afternoon after we finish the executive
schedule which I'm hoping will last no
longer than one hour
we will hear
two further we'll have public hearings
on two further bills HB 257 and HB 263
and with a little bit of luck we'll be
out of here by a reasonable hour this
afternoon maybe 4 or 4 30.
so is there any committing business to
conduct between
um before we go on a lunch break
representative notter
I would like to request that the
Republicans stay a few minutes so we can
have a caucus
good idea I was going to ask for that as
well
just as a point of of information for
members of the committee representative
lewicki
will probably out be out for an extended
period of time he was seriously ill
a week ago Friday and the good news is
he's recovering now but his recovery
likely will be fairly extensive and he
will need to rehab at the home of his
daughter in Vermont so we may not see
him for
a while
he is still in the hospital uh Southern
New Hampshire Medical Center in Nashua I
do not have an address there yet I'm
working on trying to get an address
where we can send him get well cards and
I will let you know as soon as I know
the news on representative McGee I will
defer to
well I was going to refer defer to
representative McWilliams but I guess
she's not here so I will tell you that
representative McWilliams has informed
me that her surgery was deemed to be
extremely successful she was released
from the hospital last Friday which was
two days early
which is an encouraging sign
so we're in our hearts and prayers we're
wishing representative McGee all the
best and hope to see her back here
relatively soon
okay anything else
okay
with no other business to conduct we're
officially on break I ask everyone in
the room who is not a republican member
of this committee to vacate the room so
we can have a quick caucus thank you
I'll see you at 1 30.
this is your one minute warning one
minute
this meeting will resume in one minute
okay good afternoon everyone
welcome back to the science technology
and energy committee
session for Monday February 6th it is 1
30 and we must now commence as noticed
in the calendar executive sessions we
have five bills that we're going to
bring forward for executive session
two of them
are bills that we actually already
did an executive session last Friday but
because they were noticed for today we
have to redo them according to the clerk
so we're going to do those two bills
first
so I will open an exact session on House
Bill 211 and recognize
representative Douglas Thomas
thank you Mr chairman I motion OTP hb211
representative Bernardi
thank you Mr chairman I second the
motion
it's been moved and seconded that we OTP
HB 211 is there any discussion
seeing none representative McWilliams
sorry
thank you very much chervos
um
I just wanted to summarize where we
stand on this one
um our our ongoing long-term testifier
Mike Fitzgerald from Des uh requested
this bill and he was very much in
support of making this happen we heard
an awful lot of excellent testimony
about how this would streamline and
refine the way things are handled and so
therefore I think that this is a very
good bill and I would agree with my
colleague representative Doug Thomas
okay thank you before we go any further
I forgot to introduce our substitutes
for the day Joan Hamlet representative
Hamlet is here for
representative Kat McGee
representative Marty Jack is here for
representative cretienne
representative Carol Brown is here for
representative John lowicky and
representative Ron Dunn is here for
representative Troy murder
I apologize for forgetting those
introductions initially
is there any further discussion on the
motion of OTP on House Bill 211.
see none I asked the clerk to call the
roll on the question
Doug Thomas yes
Janine nodder yes Michael Harrington yes
Ron Dunn yes
Carol Brown yes Lex barajny yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom closure yes
James Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams yes
don't Hamlet yes
Marty Jack yes
lucious partial yes Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes
Henry Noel
yes
Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman yes
Ned Reynolds yes
Mr chairman yes
and buy a vote of twenty to zero House
Bill 211
will be sent to the floor with a
recommendation of ought to pass
and with that I will close
oh that's right we're going to put this
on consent so without objection it'll go
on consent
seeing no objections it'll go on consent
and I'll close the public the executive
session on House Bill 211.
now I'll open an exact session on House
Bill 633 and I'll recognize
representative McWilliams for a motion
uh Mr chair I move itl on House Bill 633
recognize representative Thomas second
it's been moved and seconded that we itl
House Bill 633 is there any discussion
representative McWilliams
um well I believe that the sponsor of
the bill was very well-meaning in trying
to address Energy prices in this crazy
Spike that we are all dealing with here
in New Hampshire we really just couldn't
find a way to work with the bill due to
the nature of
the way the pricing would be fixed and
so therefore I recommend Ito
thank you any further discussion
representative Thomas thank you Mr chair
I concur with representative McWilliams
and also to add that there were
questions about potential
unconstitutionality as well
okay any further discussion
seeing none ask the clerk to call the
roll on the question
Doug Thomas
yes Janine nodder yes Michael Harrington
yes Ron Dunn yes Carol Brown yes Lex
barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom blochet
yes
James Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams yes
Joan hamblett yes
Marty Jack yes
lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris muns yes Henry
Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman
yes Ned Reynolds yes Mr chairman yes
20 to Zero by a vote of 20 to zero the
committee sends this bill to the house
floor with a recommendation of itl
without objective objection it will go
on the consent calendar
so you know objections this bill will go
on to the consent calendar
and with that I will close the executive
session on House Bill 633
and now we're legal
the clerk will be happy with us the
house clerk will be happy
moving right along here next up
executive session on House Bill 139
relative to the definition of Municipal
host for purposes of limited electrical
energy producers chair recognizes
Michael Harrington
uh you select the move uh inappropriate
to legislate on this bill please
chair recognizes Tom closure
I'll second that it's been moved and
seconded that we judge House Bill 139 to
be itl
discussion representative Harrington
well this is another thing that we've
continued to see uh in the expansion of
eligibility for net metering and um
it's just going to transfer more cost
shifting to rate payers a lot of who I
simply don't have the wherewithal
facilities or whatever to put in any
type of net metering or any type of
generation and I think we last term we
passed one that allowed municipals to do
that with the idea that the cost savings
would be uh uh realized by taxpayers
rather than private individuals so I
don't see any need to expand this uh
beyond what we already have
further discussion on House Bill 139
seeing none I guess I'll ask the clerk
to call the question of
itl for House Bill 139
Doug Thomas yes Denise not her yes
Michael Harrington yes
uh Ron Dunn yes Carol Brown yes Lex
brajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom closure
yes James Summers yes Rebecca well
Rebecca McWilliams no
Joan hamblett no
uh Marty Jack no lucious partial no
Melanie Kaplan nope Chris muns nope
Henry Noel no
Wendy Thomas nope Thomas Corman no
Ned Reynolds nope Mr chairman yes
10 10. buy a vote of 10 to 10 the motion
to itl fails
and the chair judges that a motion to
ought to pass would also fail so we will
send this bill to the house floor
without recommendation
representative Harrington will write the
itl position
representative Mick Williams you have
someone to write the OTP position
representative Corman
well say again please representative
Corman
representative Corman
I still can't understand
Corman okay representative Carmen will
write the position for uh ought to pass
for house bill 139.
and with that we'll close the public
here at the executive session on House
Bill 139.
moving right along
I'll open an executive session on House
Bill 166 relative to the elimination
of useful thermal energy from renewable
energy classes and I recognize
representative Doug Thomas
Mr chair uh my recommendation is to
retain this bill
I recognize
representative J.D Bernardi
I second that motion
it has been moved and seconded that we
retain house bill 166.
is there any discussion representative
Thomas
Mr chair I think we just uh this is a
complicated issue we need more time and
uh I believe that retaining it is in the
best interest of seeing if we can come
up with something that might be amenable
to both sides
thank you any further discussion foreign
to call the roll on the question of
retain for house bill 166.
Doug Thomas yes
Janine naughter yes Michael Harrington
yes Ron Dunn yes Carol Brown yes Lex
bragny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom plushie
yes James Summers yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Joan Hamlet yes
Marty Jack yes lucious partial no
Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns no
Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas no
Thomas Corman no
Ned Reynolds
yes
Mr chairman yes
16-4
by about a 15 16 to 4.
the committee votes to retain house bill
166.
by way of explanation which remembers
I'll remind everyone that retain means
that we still own this bill
we by voting to retain
we have to report that to the house
clerk once that's reported we cannot
touch this bill again until next fall
next September at that time we can take
it up again and issue some kind of a
report by the
I don't remember the exact date but some
somewhere around November 1st
so that's what will happen with this
bill
we can form a stud study committee if we
want to try to figure out if there's
something else we can do with this bill
and we can discuss that at a future date
we don't have to figure that out today
um
we do have a fair amount of work to do
today so
possibly we don't want to
well maybe we should decide that
um
as we only have one other Bill to deal
with so
is there any appetite for forwarding
forming a subcommittee to study the
issues involved in this bill
it would appear not
representative munz
uh Mr chair I I voted
um no to retain the bill because if I'm
not mistaken there was a similar Bill
introduced in the 2021 session that was
referred to study and nothing ever
happened with that so I'm not sure what
we're going to accomplish by looking at
this further so I I
don't know that a subcommittee is going
to
do anything
representative partial do you have a
comment
oh no oh I saw that your microphone was
on so I thought
representative nadles
Reynolds did you have a comment no okay
all right there doesn't seem to be much
of an appetite for forming a study
committee so we won't do that
so I guess we're done with uh House Bill
166 did I close the exact session
I closed the exact session on House Bill
166.
that leaves us with one further bill
that's House Bill
219-fn relative to certain Public public
utility statutes
so I have opened this exact session but
I'm going to recess it because
the rather lengthy Amendment that's
going to be required to fix this bill
could not be prepared in time for this
executive session
so we will resume this executive session
at a time and date to be determined and
to be noticed in the calendar
and we will
take it up then with a Amendment
that basically reconstitutes the whole
bill as a study committee to study each
and every
RSA that was listed in the original Bill
to determine should it be repealed
should it be Rewritten should it be
put somewhere else in statute just
exactly what needs to be done with it
it's a study committee that actually has
a real
defined and uh
precise purpose
so it's a study committee whose work
should go fairly well fairly quickly and
fairly smoothly
so with that I'll close no I can't close
it I got it it's recessed so I can't
close that executive session it remains
open until a future date
so we're done we got through this faster
than I thought we would
and we now have 45 minutes to kill while
we wait for the next public hearing
representative Doug Thomas has a
question uh yes Mr chair uh just a
comment here for those uh we I know that
last week we talked about HP 81 which
was the propane gas bill and so we
formed the subcommittee and so my
question is is uh my first availability
would be next Wednesday at 1 pm we can
have a subcommittee we are currently
searching for which room here to use but
if the people that were named on the
subcommittee last week if they could get
back to me and let me know that they can
make that I can't make the morning I
have a doctor's appointment but in the
afternoon one o'clock would work
uh so just let me know okay I got one
thumbs up there
two thumbs up
a waiver a
so-so and you know yeah
me too
and uh just because we have people named
on the subcommittee does not mean that
the rest of you cannot attend you're
certainly welcome to come
um
if you want to add Mr chair no
now that sounds great we I am I was told
uh just before coming in here this this
afternoon I was told that uh at that
subcommittee AmeriGas will be flying
people up from Nora from New Orleans
uh to present their fixes
and their comments I've already put my
order in for beignets I don't know about
anyone else but
that much
that is all
okay thank you see you all back here at
2 30 for a public hearing on House Bill
257.
we are in momentary recess until then
well without the customary one minute
warning I will open up HB 257 and
welcome representative chairman Vose as
the primary sponsor of this bill
thank you Mr Vice chairman good
afternoon again members of the committee
for the record representative Michael
Vose representing Rockingham District 5
the town of Epping
I'm here this afternoon to introduce
house bill 257.
and those of you who were on this
committee last year will recognize the
title of this bill which is to relative
to
relieving carriers of their carrier of
Last Resort obligation
it was a bill that passed this committee
and the house last year but then ran
into roadblocks in the Senate
and
the common wisdom is that circumstances
have changed a bit since last year and
so we're submitting this bill again in
the hopes that this year it will
meet with a more favorable reception
what this bill does is it continues the
process of the deregulation of the
telephone Marketplace
as you are no doubt well aware
much of the telephone industry was
heavily regulated
back before 1970 1996 when the
Telecommunications Act opened the
Telecommunications Market to competition
and
that
free market competition has led to much
lower prices and much greater services
in telecommunications and the years
since 1996.
the carrier of Last Resort obligation
actually dates back to like 1934. the
communications Act of that year
regulated landline companies those were
the only companies that were available
then and they were given Monopoly
territories just like utilities are
given Monopoly territories today
and back then
the telephone companies received Federal
subsidies to make sure that everybody
had access to
telephone service
while those Federal subsidies of long
since ceased
they went away with the 1996
Telecommunications Act
but the carrier of Last Resort
obligation
still resides with landline telephone
companies even though they receive no
help in paying to make those to secure
those obligations
there aren't a lot of these companies
left in New Hampshire but there are a
few several I guess and they're small
They don't serve many customers
but the carrier of Last Resort
obligation does put a fairly significant
burden on these companies to stay alive
and if we don't remove this carrier of
Last Resort obligation we may lose even
more of these companies than we've
already lost
so that's why I think it's imperative
that we seriously consider how we can
how we can make this happen now the
legislation that is before you today is
virtually identical to the legislation
that passed last year
and there may be a couple of tweaks that
can be made to it to make it
more acceptable to everyone
because ultimately the goal here is to
make sure that no person who lives in
New Hampshire
doesn't have access to at least 9-1-1
service
obviously 911
saving service and so we want to make
sure everybody in New Hampshire has
access to that service
but the reality is that in this this day
and age of cell phones in this day and
age of uh internet
activity including uh voice over IP
internet telephone service
there are very few people in our state
who don't have access to telephone
Communications
and as you'll read the text of the bill
the bill provides that this carrier of
Last Resort obligation cannot be
um eliminated unless
an area has substantial coverage from
these other kinds of telecommunication
services
so that's my introduction to the bill
there are people who will testify after
me that will give you more detail
on
various aspects of the legislation
I'm going to wrap it up for now and take
any questions from the committee and
then we'll move along
thank you
representative Vose I'm going to make a
statement uh this is a simply worded
bill I would like to have questions
asked pertaining to the Bill's Mechanics
or things that clarify the bill if you
will please thank you I'll start with
representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair
um clarifying the bill on lines three
and four it says relieved of its carrier
of Last Resort obligation in one or more
municipalities my question is are they
relieved of the obligation for the
entire municipality or is this on a
case-by-case basis within a municipality
not sure I can ask answer that question
but there are people behind me who can
okay thank you hold on to it
representative Kaplan
thank you uh Mr
standing or sitting chair and uh thanks
for taking my question Mr chair um I'm
just curious what this went to interim
study in the Senate is that correct
I don't remember exactly how the Senate
disposed of it but it did not become law
that I know but did they make do you
know if they made the following a
follow-up sorry did they have
recommendations from any interim study
do you know I do not know
representative Nutter
thank you I'm trying to remember from
last term did um the commissioner of
safety Mark Doyle come and testify for
this bill
you recall
he may have I don't recall
representative Bernardi
thank you Mr chair Mr chair do you have
a number or approximate number of how
many individuals may be affected by this
I don't but I suspect that the people
who would testify after me will have
that number thank you or be able to
estimate it
see no more questions thank you very
much for your testimony
chairman Vos and I will call on Amanda
Noonan to the stand
from the New Hampshire energy Department
thank you
better
good afternoon all thank you for the
opportunity for the Department to make
some comments on this legislation as
representative Bose noted this
legislation was also introduced last
year the Department's comments are
consistent with our testimony from last
year
this is certainly a policy decision for
the legislature and the department
doesn't have a position on this bill we
do have a few observations and potential
unintended consequences perhaps that
might fall out of this bill
um I think as you've heard has proposed
this bill would allow an incumbent
telecommunications provider to petition
the department of energy to relieve it
of its carrier of Last Resort
obligations in one or more
municipalities
um if one of two conditions exists
should the department receive a petition
to this effect it's well prior to the
department receiving a petition to this
effect it's likely that we would
undertake some rulemaking to determine
what the right procedure would be if we
received one of these petitions for
relief
there's two possible paths for that
rulemaking to follow
one would just be Reliance on any
certification provided by the
Telecommunications provider that they've
complied with the Bill's criteria
the second would be a path where there's
independent review and Analysis of the
data provided by the incumbent carrier
the department would most likely require
consultant services to carry out that
independent review to ensure that the
requirements of 95 percent of the
households having access to one or more
mobile service providers or sorry to
other competitive providers or 97
percent having access to one or more
mobile service providers are met
or that there was another provider that
had received federal state or Municipal
funds to serve the entire community
those costs of a consultant would be
assessed most likely against the
provider asking for this relief
so there'd be no cost to the to the
state or to the general fund
um as representative Bose noted the
Telecommunications industry in New
Hampshire is primarily deregulated and
has been for some period of time
um competition has provided a number of
Alternatives and lower costs for
customers
and while competition among
telecommunication providers is fairly
robust in some areas of New Hampshire
cities larger municipalities towns where
there's a more denser a better
population density
many rural areas of the state don't have
the same level of access to service
providers into options and alternatives
those rural areas due to their geography
are most likely less likely to have
ubiquitous wireless service as we've all
experienced the frustrations of
traveling throughout the state and
having no coverage on our cell phones
the carry of Last Resort the incumbent
telecommunications Services obligation
to provide service to provide landline
service to those customers provides
those folks with access to essential
communication services
while this bill would allow the care of
last the incumbent provider to be
relieved of its carrier of Last Resort
obligation
if the department found that the
appropriate criteria were met there are
no other criteria in the bill regarding
service availability or any requirement
to serve all customers in a given area
and
if you think about cell phone coverage
for example it's an area where we're
concerned that the bill could lead to
some percentage of households being
unable to access essential communication
services such as emergency services
medical services customers that rely on
their landline service to provide data
to a physician about their their medical
condition
similarly an incumbent can request
relief if there's a provider that's
received state or federal or Municipal
funding to serve the entire municipality
but there's no discussion about what
that service is and whether it would be
landlines or not landline service but
phone service traditional phone service
or VoIP phone service some sort of voice
service or if it's simply a broadband
service that wouldn't provide actual
voice Communication Service
I think most importantly the the
criteria for permitting an incumbent
carrier to be relieved of its care of
last resort obligation is based on the
competitive land landscape at a single
point in time
and that landscape changes and it could
be whatever conditions are pushing an
incumbent provider to ask for relief
from its carrier of Last Resort
obligations may also
result in that provider
reducing some of its services or
discontinuing some of its services and
those same circumstances that drive it
to do that may drive other providers in
that area to reduce or discontinue
services without that carrier flash
Resort obligation you risk having big
pockets of a community potentially
without access to telecommunications
services
um
I understand no one wants to see
customers in the State lose access to
essential services and I I think there
are some pitfalls to avoid if you look
at moving forward with this bill and
hopefully that helps you identify some
of them and happy to ask answer I don't
have to ask but happy to answer any
questions you might have
representative Corman please
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
so I am concerned about people who don't
have access to wireless service also
losing the capability for landline one
concern I would have just is defining
who has wireless service because just
because you have a Wireless contract
doesn't mean you have service at your
home but the real question that I have
for you is
do we have a way to determine how many
people are in this situation I don't
expect that you have that number now but
is there a methodology to determine that
some time ago the Federal Communications
Commission authorized some studies about
how ubiquitous wireless coverage was and
whether that coverage matched the maps
of the service providers it would need
to take a look at that study it was
perhaps
2015 16 17 time frame to see if there
was some um
formula or analysis in there for
determining the coverage
Riverside months
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question just to follow up on
representative Corman so in the bill it
you know sets some some
um some thresholds 95 percent
um
and 97 for various types of service so
do we do we know what the what that
number is right now for each
municipality
we at the department don't have that
information no
it's a follow-up follow-up so is that
part of the study that you're suggesting
that the that the the department would
have to do if this went forward as part
of the rulemaking
that's exactly right if we received a
petition and we're going to do an
independent review and Analysis of the
data that is part of the study we'd have
to do for the affected municipality
representative Winnie Thomas
Mr chair
um do you have an idea of the cost
savings by telephone utilities if they
got relieved of this obligation
I do not telephone providers have been
deregulated for rates for
10 plus years so I would have no way of
knowing what that cost might be okay I
suspect they can tell you and we'll tell
you later okay thank you
thank you see no questions so thank you
for your testimony and we'll move on I'm
not sure I can get this last name
correct uh Teresa
yes
and just for my record
am I uh there am I on now great uh I'm
Theresa Rosenberger and I apologize for
the bad handwriting
um and I'm here representing the New
Hampshire telephone Association and I I
work for Bernstein sure uh the New
Hampshire telephone Association are the
old Ma Bell companies and
um they are at the moment uh Bretton
Woods telephone Dunbarton telephone
Granite State telephone TDS telephone
which is the old Wilton Hollis Etc and
Consolidated Communications years ago we
also had dixville telephone but as
Amanda Noonan knows it took years and
dixville was dissolved because they only
had five customers
but it took years
so the old mobile companies as
representative Bose said back in 1934
where the communications act they were
awarded monopolies they were awarded
territories these territories do not
necessarily which is maybe going to
answer your question follow Town lines
they were territory so you have for
example over in Plainfield you have
Consolidated and TDS so they are both in
the town and in other towns you have
them just one one carry it just depended
on how way back in almost 30 years 100
years ago they divvied up the map so
these are your old mobile companies your
monopolies when they were given their
Monopoly they were required to have
quote duty to serve all the territory so
if you awarded the Monopoly for Concord
you had to serve all of Concord not just
here but all of conquered then back in
1996 the feds passed the
Telecommunications Act of 96 and the
goal of that was to bring in competition
you were beginning to have wireless you
were beginning to have all these other
Technologies well let me just say it has
worked and it has worked wonderfully
there's competition now across the board
you've even got today not just
telecommunications companies you've got
municipalities you've got electric
co-ops you've certainly got Wireless
landline voice satellite so you've got
competition across the board I will say
also one of the goals of competition was
to bring down the rates and I will say I
was in the house Ways and Means
Committee last week and there was a
question why is the communication
Services tax revenue going down
because the rates are going down
competition is in my in my house I have
to tell you we switched service last
year the rates went down a third and I
thought holy cow so there is definitely
competition
even when I'll give you an example last
year the state awarded Through The Fez
50 million dollars to the New Hampshire
Electric Co-op to build broadband and it
was very interesting what they did
um
they the co-op was not at was not um
did not have to put any money in
to this build the co-op unlike my
clients does not have a union and the
co-op is a non-profit so it's not paying
the taxes the other thing they did in a
Hampshire did when New Hampshire put out
this
um Broadband proposal
and they were going off of federal
guidelines not federal mandates but
federal guidelines that if you you got a
higher score if you were a municipality
a non-profit or a Cooperative so for
example when this came out last summer
all of my clients the most they could
score if they applied to get this money
was 75 percent
the co-op or a municipality get a
hundred percent
so as you can imagine cable landline
while we all screamed and yelled and
said wait a minute this is just
blatantly unfair we've all spent all
this money we're continuing to build and
we can't you know if you didn't score 70
you got thrown out so unless you were
perfect and none of my clients are
perfect so needless to say we were all
going to get thrown out So eventually
they amended it and put it at 90 percent
so obviously
um we didn't win none of the none of the
for-profit companies Comcast
Consolidated Charter TDS nobody nobody
won the co-op one they put out round two
and guess what we can still only score
90 percent
so now when they go to the next
iteration
the for-profits can apply and can I
think score 100 but they have to put 25
capital in
the reason I'm telling you this is not
to whine as I did for a long time about
how unfair this was but to tell you when
you look at a competitive landscape and
you've got for-profits are spending
their own money and then and the case of
one of my clients they they have a union
and they're paying taxes and then all of
a sudden you still have government
regulation of being the carry of Last
Resort when you've got complete
competition in an area
you're Shackled and and so we believe
this bill is taking us forward in
deregulation now for us we're having to
maintain old and for those of you I
think who've been here a long time well
no years ago and I think representative
Noel you were here a while back and I'm
back again we've talked about copper and
fiber Etc well most of these carrier
blast resorts are copper so we're having
my clients are having to maintain that
copper line as well as they're building
fiber at the same time and what you've
got you've got to maintain two systems
now you take Concord for example they're
being built out completely in fiber well
why do you then need to maintain a a
copper Network it's expensive
so I would surmise that we would be
better as a state because the federal
money is not going to go to Every rural
area and build out that last mile
I think from a resource perspective we'd
be better to take that money of
maintaining that old Network for carry
of Last Resort and building out those
rural municipalities where the last mile
still isn't going to go to with all that
Federal money because you've got
companies who are willing to invest
and two I'm not sure who asked the
question about the race it was you with
you representative the rate
really I think in many ways what you're
going to see happen is the companies
take that Capital these spending
maintaining an old Antiquated system and
then using it frankly to build out
places with fiber in the North Country
Etc the other issue you've got here I
hate to say it and Sarah Davis can talk
about it more than I the question is how
long is it going to be before you can't
get parts for that old Network and so
then you've got your think you've got a
carry of Last Resort but you really
don't because you don't have the parts
and the equipment to maintain it so I
think this is a good time for New
Hampshire to really look at beginning to
move forward of finding a way that we
can make sure everybody's got 9-1-1
everybody's got fire they've got police
but they're on new technology and using
multiple types of technology and we are
relieving this Antiquated system from
way back way back when I kind of got off
my script but um the bottom line here is
we did back in 2012 past Senate Bill 48
which started deregulation as Mrs Noonan
said we are getting there
most of the country we have 38 states
that have already uh moved and some of
them a long time ago to relieve
companies completely of the carry a last
resort or to allow companies to do what
we're asking here which is only petition
Maine for example their law went in
2016. Vermont all our neighboring states
this is only enabling legislation so all
you're doing is allowing a company to be
able to position the puc the company's
not going to waste their time or
resources if they don't have meet the
criteria here so what are we really
talking about Concord
Manchester maybe Nash it's going to be
your big cities
I mean I here in Concord we have the
choice of Consolidated Comcast Breeze
line and every single wireless carrier
as well as you can have satellite as
well so for a company they're really
only going to position the puc if
they're sure they've got coverage across
the board and you're going to see this
as one or more Wireless carriers and so
you're going to see you're going to see
nobody's going to waste their time
frankly petitioning the puc for Mylon or
Romney or anything like that you're
gonna you're gonna that's I'd say
another decade down the road down the
road
um I think I have I'm hoping I've
answered the questions but again this is
the enabling legislation it's on us to
prove that there is competition clearly
with the co-op getting the money the
companies were having to figure out how
to prove the over Bill the companies
know how to do that and they would have
to and if the puc says we don't think
you proved it correctly you've got to go
back to the drawing board
so thank you I think I covered
everything but I didn't please ask me uh
thank you question uh representative
Kaplan
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming and testifying I didn't answer
your question
um I have a question for you okay but I
forgot to answer the one you asked
before but I will okay
um you mentioned that the Legacy
carriers might choose to install fiber
optic cable instead of maintaining the
old copper lines that might be a you
know logical choice for them
I was wondering if the telephone
carriers might be open to an amendment
that said going forward the the you know
from here on
the carriers would not be liable to
carry that last mile obligation for new
houses but they you know so they
wouldn't have to install new lines but
they would still have to maintain the
old lines would that make sense
I think if I understand you you're
saying when these new construction you
don't have to have the carry of Last
Resort obligation and that you would
install fiber
well let me say here everybody's
installing fiber now and so nobody is
gonna nobody's gonna install uh copper
and it's going to be fiber uh that
doesn't really get us where we're going
because you'd only be be eliminating
carry of Last Resort for new
construction and really when you think
about it if you are in Manchester or
Concord and you've got the choice of
four or five Wireless carriers and
you've got at least two cable and at
least one landline and in this case
landline other landlines could come in
then
wouldn't it make more sense to let them
be relieved because everybody can dial
9-1-1 and then build out some of these
areas in the other parts of the state
that are more rural so we could get
everybody that they had choices like we
do in our big cities so I didn't really
answer your question but I I think we'd
be better off to do it and you can only
do it for one area so as representative
Thomas asked you you you could do two
two areas together but they both have to
be whatever your area is it's got to
still meet the qualifications here but
to answer your other question that you
asked before about what happened in the
Senate I will honestly say we had
support for it in the Senate and um I'm
going to politely say it was what I call
an administrative glitch and the bill
the the exact session ran over other
people were coming in and it was put it
in a room setting and they did not meet
on it
so it was it was one of the more
frustrating bills I've dealt with in
years where you thought oh gosh couldn't
you have a debate but it was you know we
got to leave the room so okay thank you
very much um we're not going to carry a
debate on here on no what could be done
or done uh if you have I'll take one
more question goes we do need to move on
all right representative Community
Thomas ask your pertinent question
um thank you Mr chair my pertinent
question is you've used the phrases or
the terms area region and municipality
can you just clarify exactly what those
are
well I can't really clarify well let me
just say
for a telephone Monopoly an old Monopoly
they were given a territory so that
territory like I gave the example in
Playing Field that territory included
half a playing field and the other towns
surrounding it it didn't include the
they didn't do it by by Town border and
so that's why you have there with
Consolidated having part of playing
field and and TDS having the other part
so they gave them territory some of them
bigger than others uh example Granite
State telephone has where and they've
got all of where so if by chance where
were a town that qualified they would
come in with a petition for all where
so it's it they didn't follow the town
map I'm not sure if all the towns were
here in 34 times right thank you I think
they answered the question yeah thank
you
um we're going to move on here thank you
so much for testimony I'm going to call
on Catherine heck next
from nhma
sir
thank you
good afternoon my name is Catherine heck
I represent nhma and thank you for
allowing me this opportunity to testify
today on House Bill 257. at this time we
continue to be opposed to the
legislation as we do believe it's still
slightly premature as written however we
do recognize that many other states have
begun the process of relieving their
carrier of Last Resort obligations and
they've done so in a very methodical and
spelled out type of way
I don't want to repeat any testimony
that you've already heard one of our
main objections is of course 911 service
and making sure people have access to
9-1-1 and we know that there's many
pockets in areas in the state even right
here in Concord that don't have wireless
coverage for such a thing as a 9-1-1
call so
the state of New Hampshire is very
actively working through the Broadband
initiative through Bea the Bureau of
economic Affairs to address the
Broadband concerns Statewide and they
are engaged in a comprehensive mapping
program which is expected to be finished
this spring so kind of crossing over
this legislation the reason why we
require more comprehensive mapping is
because currently all our broadband and
wireless data is based on census tract
data from the US government and that
means if you ping one household and they
have that data and what's considered a
census Block it's considered to be
served
whether or not everyone in that area is
served or not so we do not have firm
data on how many are underserved but we
do know for example some towns looked to
move forward with Broadband projects to
bring the Last Mile in and because of
census tract data they were considered
to be served there's currently a bill in
the Senate to ensure that bonding can
now be bonding on the municipal level
can happen for both underserved and
unserved so underserved was currently
not an option for bonding but we
recognize that that middle and last mile
of broadband it's critical so to give
you an example up north and Northern as
we talked about the co-op we do know
that our most northern neighbors are the
most underserved or unserved in the
state and they worked with the state of
New Hampshire they were awarded as a
fellow testifier just stated a a grant
from the state of New Hampshire to build
out and they will be building out
between 30 35 and 40 000 people who did
not have service so that that's a
significant number of people who may be
affected by this bill now the number
exactly is still hard to know who would
be 95 or 97 percent unserved so that's
just an example but that's only one
region of the state
um
there are additional grants under the
capital projects fund that will go to
Private Industry for broadband and
wireless bill though there was 122
million dollars in the capital projects
fund I believe about 40 million has been
awarded and they're continuing to take
rfps so I've put some links into my
testimony I'll email it to you so you
can access those links for example and
you can see what the state of New
Hampshire is doing to address this issue
so we'd be happy to work with the
sponsors and talk about how other states
did it how this could be framed in a way
that could work for New Hampshire given
that we are moving forward very
diligently as a state to get broadband
service to all of our residents and
Wireless Communications
and I did want to point out that for
example the state of Maine has a
commission that they've created they
have a statute they go through it
methodically and they decide it's all
available
um in my testimony which I'll email and
I do have hard copies so that you can
see how they've gone about relieving the
carrier Last Resort of their obligation
so it's possible but I feel like it's
premature without this comprehensive
mapping that our state is currently
working on so we really understand how
many people would be affected by this
legislation so I'll just take questions
thank you
I have one question from representative
munz
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
joining us today I had earlier asked the
representative from the Department of
energy if we had a handle on how many
people were affected by this I'm I take
it that this this mapping exercise would
answer that question is that correct
that is correct sir so that's why we
were hoping that that would be
incorporated somehow into this
legislation so it can't be enacted
without using the map to reference the
spont the department of Energy's
testimony she stated that
it could be up to the carrier to prove
that someone you know that they they
meet the criteria and then they would
have someone vet that we feel like
having a comprehensive map that everyone
has to reference that the state has
developed and we know it's done with
Fidelity would provide those
reassurances that everyone
um
is being treated equally and fairly
under this legislation follow-up
I'll take one follow-up in your in your
testimony
um you indicate that that exercise would
be completed sometime later in 2023
would can you give us any better idea of
when that might happen well I actually
was on a just a call with Bea this
morning that's accessible to everyone
and I did ask that very pointed question
to prepare for this testimony and they
were hoping to have it by the first
quarter of this year to start going
through the preliminary mapping data so
again I I don't have an exact date but
they're very hopeful because Bea is
looking to distribute those funds based
on the map that's produced from this RFP
that they put out
thank you I think I'm sensing the
questions or getting back to the your
testimony again uh the same information
uh thank you for your testimony I'm
going to call on Sarah Davis next and uh
don't take this as anything different
um I failed to make an announcement
earlier that if you do have written
testimony please we can read please just
summarize your written testimony and you
can add to it if you think it's a
pertinent to that bill so thank you very
much welcome Miss Davis uh the floor is
yours thank you very much as you stated
my name is Sarah Davis and I am with
Consolidated Communications and I'm here
testifying in favor of this bill I
appreciate the opportunity I will not
bore you I will not read my testimony I
will address some of the issues I heard
before me and try to try to anticipate
some of the questions so this bill is an
attempt to move in a direction that is
not drastic for the State of New
Hampshire to start working towards
what's a very basic issue that at this
point in time Consolidated for instance
has about eight percent of the access
lines it had just 17 years ago yet it
still has to maintain the millions of
miles of facilities that it has up in
the air to provide those same Services
when it had 92 percent more access lines
and so what that leaves is a situation
where to continue to be viable the
company has to continue increasing rates
in for those telecommunications Services
which is not a direction that it wants
to go but
still having to maintain an obligation
and unfunded mandate in the state
without you know the the customer base
or the Monopoly protection to guarantee
a rate of return at the end of that puts
you in this position and so we have
followed what we did in Maine I heard
main reference earlier we followed what
we did in Maine and we're trying to move
forward in a way that allows the company
to be relieved of that obligation in any
area where there is sufficient
competition it is not being asked to be
relieved of that in areas where there is
no other providers in very rural areas
as areas where there is sufficient
competition as Miss Rosenberger stated
an area like Plymouth today has almost
100 percent competition by Charter as
well as Wireless providers and the New
Hampshire Electric Co-op was just given
millions of dollars to overbuild and
provide fiber to the Prem service that
is an area where it may make sense for
Consolidated to not continue to provide
service since there's two options in the
area it can thereby save the money there
and deploy in other areas where service
may be needed more that's the basic
issue in front of us and we're trying to
move forward in a very smart way to
answer the question over here the bill
speaks to municipality that's
intentional because a consumer doesn't
always understand an exchange or an area
or a region a consumer knows what
municipality they live in and so the
attempt is if that municipality in total
re achieves that criteria you are
relieved of that obligation in a
municipality we believe it's very
difficult for consumers to understand
portions or regions or other areas that
are not Geographic that they they don't
have a clear understanding so it was
written on a municipal basis over here
there was a question about the cost to
do that it's impossible to get the exact
cost because you'd have to look at each
area but I'll give you some I'll give
you some references
so for pole attachments just in the PSNH
area if we move forward with our pole
sale transaction Consolidated would pay
over five million dollars just to to
keep facilities up
Consolidated is probably the largest
Electric customer in the state so in all
of these areas it pays very high
electric bills millions of dollars a
year these are all costs that to some
extent could be avoided in very urban
areas if the company decides that it
doesn't make sense to continue there
because competition has reducer access
lines so low I was trying to think of
some of the other questions before us
you heard about Maine creating a
commission I just want to clarify Maine
did not create a commission the
commission that oversaw deregulation in
Maine like is proposed in this bill was
the Public Utilities Commission here
you've split up into the Public
Utilities Commission and the doe hence
why the doe is doing that but it it was
in the Public Utilities Commission a
separate commission was not created
there also was not study it was 21
municipalities were automatically deemed
competitive I also heard that the
mapping is on a census block basis from
the FCC in January that is not in fact
the case in January the FCC produced its
fabric mapping and that is on you can go
see it it's right online on the FCC
website that is pinpoints each household
and lists the service pro the service
available and the number of service
providers available for each one of
those households
I think that is most of the questions
that were asked I'm sure you have more
though
okay uh representative summer do you
have a short question
yeah this just pertains to uh to
Consolidated expanding something like
that as far as Last Mile the one
question I have about that is if I have
a company as it says industry or a farm
let's say The Last Mile if the head in
unit is at the end of the road and I
have to run a line a mile to my house or
a company to do that is that fall under
the responsibility of the consumer to
pay for the the dig out or the trench or
the aerial for that instead of it
falling on the rate pairs now is the
consumer responsible for that
yes for the most part so the consumer is
responsible for the facilities so if
polls or conduit are required generally
the telephone company picks up the cable
so
and that's a bit of a simplification
because there's so many feet the
consumer gets but in general that's the
story
okay see no more questions thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
appreciate it appreciate the opportunity
we have one last speaker Mr David
Marston
and Mr Marston I know you've requested
seven to ten minutes but prorated can
you keep it down to about one minute one
minute
um
I feel like I have many issues that have
not come up yet I I see that as being
very difficult but I will burn through
as best I can I'm David Marston just a
ordinary subscriber to a landline I like
a landline because it has better
Fidelity and it works during a power
failure
uh back in ancient times the Telco is
signed up to provide Universal service
they knew what they were signing up for
later on the FCC gave them a mechanism
so that telcos could decline service to
a particular individual subscriber that
was just impossibly remote but now we're
faced with this bill it says 97 coverage
of the municipality is adequate instead
of a hundred percent why is that what
about the other three percent uh and
possibly more this measurement called
for in the bill only talks about
households not about the farms and
businesses or other users so the many
possible losers in this dropping of the
carrier of Last Resort only a handful of
winners uh perhaps if the eye likes the
Consolidated and other incumbent
companies are in that much financial
trouble we need something that's a
broader view of what their financial
issues are
uh this bill talks exclusively about pot
service plain old telephone service what
you might call your landline without the
extras that take it above the plane
level you know voicemail and all that
but there are many other kinds of
services provided by those incumbent
telephone companies including
non-switched lease lines such as alarm
circuits in fact there are several dozen
different kinds of services yet the bill
does not provide for consideration of
the impact of the withdrawal of those
services
uh signaling over the Internet or over
pots the potential Alternatives is less
secure than using dedicated lease lines
directly between the remote site and the
communications up
and cable companies like Comcast
generally don't want to offer unbundled
alarm circuits so you're taking business
away from small businesses in New
Hampshire the alarm companies that can
use an unbundled alarm line when there
is the incumbent telephone company
providing that coverage
these local companies are also more
versatile regarding the types of
conditions that they can monitor with
their alarms
the wired telecommunications Network
that we are talking about possibly
dismantling parts of is the foundation
upon which other companies build the
switched telephone Network possibly
several layers on that the internet and
other networks built on leased lines for
example the Associated Press has a
network that goes out to all their
customers that is lease lines
and if you change or disrupt that
Network you need to talk about all the
services not just the plain old
telephone service that is called for in
the bill measure all the availability of
all the services
there's no mention of any kind of notice
of any type whatsoever not even after
the petition is approved to the affected
parties and first and foremost on the
list of affected parties is the
municipality itself because they are the
most likely to need service in obscure
parts of town the kinds of last miles
that the incumbent Telco would be
looking to drop most eagerly the state
of New Hampshire you think about the
transportation department fish and games
state parks they also require service in
obscure parts of towns that might not
have residential subscribers nearby but
residential subscribers themselves are
threatened possible losers if they're in
the abandoned three percent or like me
they want better Fidelity on their
Communications
other utilities
and I would particularly call out
electric companies remember I said that
you get a much more secure network for
monitoring and control when you have
dedicated lease lines this is an
important national security issue for
the electric companies they do not want
to control the grid over the Internet
they want dedicated lease lines they
have facilities such as dams and wind
turbines and solar arrays that are out
in obscure parts of town again those
last miles that these telcos would be
looking to drop
also just in general businesses Academia
non-profit organizations your usual
non-residential telephone subscribers
but other affected parties are
developers trying to consider where they
might build new facilities residential
or non-residential in a municipality
there is no notification required to any
of these parties about what's going on
according to the bill it just happens
no announcement
no chance to challenge the evidence
being provided by the petitioner
so we don't know what's going on when do
we even have a matter of record that a
person could check years in the future
oh they dropped their carrier of Last
Resort they don't have one in that
municipality
uh we have talked a bit with the various
people testifying about municipalities
as service territories
uh let's clarify that there is a
division of the state into Telco service
areas it's a whole map tiling off the
state and other than the dropping of
dixville there has been no reduction in
incumbent telephone service around the
state now there might be fewer companies
because of acquisitions by TDS
but there is a number of different cases
where
the map of the towns has a disjoint
appearance relative to the map of the
Telco service areas for example Grant
State Communications provides pot
service Plano telephone service in
Hopkinton Deering Hillsboro New Boston
even Dairy now you think Dairy you think
oh that's a Consolidated territory but
no parts of dairy because the Chester
telephone company are actually served by
Granite State
uh Dunbarton same thing parts of Bowen
Goffstown so the petition is a company
like Dunbarton could say well we don't
want to serve Ghost Town anymore this
little sliver we're serving I believe
it's actually less than three percent so
they can show Numbers based on some
other company and how they serve it's
the rest of golf Scott Goffstown and say
look there's enough service we can drop
out Mr Marston are you if I read us some
up please I've given you a lot more time
thank you I asked you to all right well
there there are a number of other issues
that I will submit in writing but I
would ask where is the puc in all this
it's it seems like there's a lot more
concerns a lot more need to have
interest represented and I am not
calling simply for heavily amending the
bill
changes of this type are so basic we
need to step back and look at what do we
actually achieve if we take away
Universal service and the carrier of
Last Resort and then look at the effect
on the national Telecom Network and then
go from there thank you
thank you you did bring up some
interesting points thank you very much
seeing no questions thank you so much
for your testimony I have no other pink
bills here so we'll end this testimony
on HB 257 and I'll close
and ask representative poche for the
blue sheet comments
and thank you chair
House Bill 257 the blue sheet had no
supporters one opposed in support and
online there was two
in support one a post thank you
represent Rose
foreign
we'll be starting a public hearing on
House Bill 263 FN in about three minutes
if you would like to testify on this
bill if you could submit a pink card I'd
appreciate it thank you
and the Hawaiian present no after Lee
yeah I think that will be perfect thank
you
while we're waiting
I'll point out to those assembled here
and those watching at home that tomorrow
this committee will meet commencing at
nine o'clock to hear public hearings on
House Bill 281
relative to least cost integrated
research resource plans of utilities
House Bill 298 relative to placement of
personal wild wireless service
facilities
House Bill 558 relative to electric
microgrids and electric grid
resiliency
although I have a question in my mind
whether that's the right title for that
bill
uh House Bill 605 relative to solar
generation under the renewable portfolio
standard
then at 1 pm we'll be having an
executive session
on four bills HB 161 HB 81 HB 381 and HB
385.
followed at 2 30
by presentations public hearings rather
on
hb616 and hb622
so another full day of activity tomorrow
foreign
okay it is finally 3 30. so I will open
a public hearing on House Bill
263 FN and ask the prime sponsor of this
legislation representative Rebecca
McWilliams
to tell us what it's all about
thank you chervos for the record my name
is Rebecca McWilliams I'm a
representative from South Concord also I
am already late to present another bill
so I'm going to present this quickly and
then I need to duck out my apologies I
know we're running a little bit late
um you've already heard testimony on
House Bill 234 regarding the practice of
wreck sweeping consider this testimony a
review and deeper discussion in regards
to how we protect our constituents from
potential conversion of their personal
property
Rec sweeping authorizes State seizure of
renewable energy property
without the knowledge of or any
compensation to New Hampshire businesses
and residents this practice is known as
wreck sweeping and it enables both
private multi-billion dollar
out-of-state corporations and in-state
utilities to use this renewable energy
in which New Hampshire residents invest
to meet their obligations not the
residence obligations these other
corporations obligations under the
renewable portfolio standard or RPS
in the case of a business this deprives
the original investors of their right to
Market their business as powered by
renewable energy or even claim they use
the renewable energy that they produce
on site I'm thinking this could happen
to a farm or to a manufacturing client
any firm doing so is vulnerable to
costly Federal Trade Commission
enforcement action or even criminal
prosecution by the New Hampshire
attorney general and fines of up to a
hundred thousand dollars under the New
Hampshire consumer protection act this
is not chump change if you are having
your wreck swept and you still claim
that you're producing renewable energy
legal opinion obtained from multiple
members of the New Hampshire bar affirms
the state seizure constitutes an
unconstitutional taking of private
property and violates the taking clause
in part 1 article 12 of the New
Hampshire Constitution
this practice has
in effect wrecked
as in destroyed the New Hampshire Rec
Renewable Energy Credit market and
significantly reduce the need for
alternative compliance payments which is
a source of funding for the renewable
energy fund our state's Soul mechanism
for investing in the clean energy
transition
the argument that this could increase
electricity bills is Pennywise and pound
foolish as any possible increase
resulting from rectifying this practice
would be literally Pennies on the
average monthly bill most likely around
the order of six cents in contrast
investments in renewable energy can pay
off in the hundreds of millions of
dollars in lower demand for out-of-state
fossil fuels lower Peak demand improved
air quality more jobs and increased
in-state economic activity
as the only lawyer on this committee I
am very concerned that absent action in
this session we may be allowing an
unconstitutional statutory provision to
stand
this could result after sending House
Bill 234 to the floor
without a committee recommendation
should that happen we should at least
provide the constitutionally necessary
due process protection of adequate
notice to our constituents the residents
and businesses of this state where there
is a state taking of property
with a property right interest there
must be at the minimum notification to
the affected parties
this applies even to putatively
state-created interests or government
assistance and the course the the case
that I would cite for this is 1978 New
Hampshire Supreme Court case Roy RV
Department of Employment Security
where it was determined that the due
process clause of the State Constitution
requires the state to provide notice
before it terminated a person's
employment benefits
turning to the text of the bill before
us beginning on page one line eight
the bill requires annual notification to
all customer generators affected by this
statute by written notice that their
energy production will be credited to
the providers of electricity both the
utilities and the competitive suppliers
unless this person obtains certification
to be issued class 1 or Class 2
certificates
this notice shall inform such applicants
of the options available to them and the
consequences of their production being
credited to Providers of electricity
that the renewable attributes of their
generation have been stripped and
assigned to those corporations
this notice shall also provide
instructions on how such applicants May
obtain certification to be issued class
1 or Class 2 certificates
in regards to the due process argument
the New Hampshire Supreme Court has held
that where governmental action would
affect a legally protected interest the
due process clause of the New Hampshire
Constitution part 1 Article 15
guarantees to the holder of the interest
the right to be heard at a meaningful
time and in a meaningful manner a
fundamental requirement of the
constitutional right to be heard in New
Hampshire
his notice of the impending action that
affords the party an opportunity to
protect the interest
the court went on to say we therefore
require and this was a puc Supreme Court
case
we therefore require the puc's
meticulous compliance
with the Constitutional mandate where
the agency action agency's action
implicates private rights this is an
appeal of conquered steam 130 New
Hampshire 422 from 427 to 428 which was
a decision in 1988.
I will email a copy of the New Hampshire
Supreme Court's 1978 decision in Royer
the Department of Employment Security in
which the Court held that the state
procedural due process clause required
notice prior to terminating employment
unemployment benefits that were fully a
government-granted benefit created by
the legislature so even if for the sake
of argument one accepts the premise that
renewable attributes are State created
Property interest or a government
benefit New Hampshire Supreme Court case
law establishes the government cannot
deprive an individual of them without at
least providing notice
foreign
I would be glad to work on a
subcommittee if there are specific edits
needed to pass this bill but this
rectifies a problem of lack of notice
and therefore a taking with no notice
under both the U.S and the New Hampshire
Constitution and I apologize that I
won't be able to stay for questions I
need to run to another committee but
thank you for your time
thank you representative McWilliams for
submitting this legislation
and good luck with your next bill
introduction
so now we'll have a conversation no
doubt with the honorable Lee oxenham
from Plainfield
who I suspect was a
played a large part in the creation of
this legislation so
I'm sure we'll have an interesting
conversation welcome back representative
or former representative good to see you
again thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you colleagues for being here and
listening
I will focus my testimony today on the
fiscal note to HB 263 and if you have
that in front of you it might be helpful
to um just bring that out and and have
it next to you I seem to have left mine
at my chair
first the note claims that there will be
a fifteen thousand dollar cost attached
to passing this bill do you need excuse
me do you need a copy of the fiscal note
um I think I have everything in my nose
but it might it might be very helpful
thank you very much I do appreciate that
I don't know what I do with it thank you
representative Reynolds for providing
that thank you
so the note claims that there's a
fifteen thousand dollar cost attached
which is the reason presumptively why
there's a fiscal note but there is no
such requirement in this bill there is
no necessary funding impact no increased
burden or lessened benefit to any rate
payer from this bill page three lines
one through eight provides a method of
notification via the utilities and the
installers that cost the state nothing
though it may minimally increase these
companies costs by adding a
communication requirement to documents
they already pay for and mail out to
their customers
much more importantly this note raises a
series of other issues
the claim is made in the note that quote
in addition getting this list of
specific people who are interconnected
and not rec registered will not be an
easy undertaking and cannot be
guaranteed
not the kind of language you usually see
in a fiscal note
and it's also
raises a fundamental question I've I've
circulated a document which has to do
with the administrative rules and you'll
see three arrows on the front page that
will point you to the points that I will
be making now the rec sweeping
regulations codified as puc
2503.04 B1 B1 through two
specifically require the distribution
utilities to provide the puc with the
name of everyone quote who is
interconnected and not rec registered
as well as the location of their system
which in the vast majority of cases will
also be the home or business address to
which this notice should be sent
so the claim that is made in this note
that getting the list
will not be an easy undertaking and
cannot be guaranteed
raises a rather fundamental question are
they not collecting this information
have they not been collecting the
information for the last decade are they
not ensuring that the utilities are
complying with their own administrative
rules
one can only posit that the fiscal note
is based on representations made to OLS
by the department of energy
and the statement
ostensibly refers to their difficulty in
accessing this data it is the case that
the regulation which is currently online
continues to cite the puc and continues
to cite the 20
um
the capacity Factor at 20 for solar
which was uh changed recently I think in
the last biennium
nevertheless uh these these matters are
not the essential point the essential
point is
location and name which are the two
things required for notice are required
that data must be in the hands of the
puc and we should be able to get it and
the doe should be able to get it
note the Rex sweeping regulations
[Music]
um
I'm sorry another issue raised by the
rules under A3 quote the certificates or
generation attributes must not have been
used for compliance with any similar
requirements of another non-federal
jurisdiction or otherwise sold retired
claimed or represented as part of any
other electrical energy output thermal
energy output portfolio or sale
now I would submit that that language
fully substantiates the testimony
presented last week under hb234 that
the state is fully aware that the
renewable attributes are the property
interest they recognize that they can't
use those renewable attributes and no
one else can unless there is exclusive
control over the property interest so it
says directly in the um in the handout
that unless these conditions are met
they cannot be used and that is the
thrust of the argument here that they
have been stripped from their owners the
customer generator they have been seized
by the state and they have been
allocated to private corporations and
the public utilities without notice
without compensation this is a
significant legal constitutional issue
and it has been raised previously
when this bill came before this
Committee in a previous biennium that
those who are affected should take the
matter to court
well taking the matter to court is an
extremely costly Venture extremely
costly in the hundreds of thousands of
dollars and that cost would have to be
borne by the customer generators
and the state would have to defend
against this
unprincipled I would claim action and
that will be on the cost of the
taxpayers
the legislature can fix this and I think
a subcommittee that would look at this
bill and consider it in the in
in a way that it has not been looked at
previously
and I will take some responsibility for
that because it is an incredibly complex
issue and I've been working on this for
uh you helped me out chair Vos is it
four years or is it six years we've been
working on this bill
um but it's it's a long time a long time
but I think I think we by having taken
the initial steps for legal prosecution
having obtained the legal opinions of
numerous members of the New Hampshire
bar
it's now clear that this statute should
not stand that it does represent a
taking by the state without notice
clearly without compensation none
and that cannot stand by the terms of
numerous New Hampshire Supreme Court
cases so please save the taxpayers the
money
save the customer generators
and let's resolve this issue and so the
future St committees will not have to
consider it yet again
and I will take questions
I was certain you would
thank you and I'm glad you would thank
you
so I will start with a couple of
questions regarding the
New Hampshire code of administrative
rules handout that you sent it that you
gave us
you stated that
Rule
2503.04 net meter and credit States
that a provider
foreign
and Class 2 certificate credits for the
production of electricity
that is net metered
that can only happen provided
you okay provided that the certificates
or generation attributes have not been
used for compliance with any similar
requirements doesn't that simply say
that uh
if you abandon your Rex then the
utility can use those
wrecks or you or use those credits
that's what that language says
uh
I I certainly disagree and and most
importantly there is no case of
Abandonment here abandonment has a very
legal meaning and it requires property
to have been out of use for periods of
years there's no issue here of property
abandonment the issue is people who know
nothing about this situation who have
invested tens of thousands of dollars in
creating generation capacity to assist
the state in moving forward with the
clean energy transition who have have
worked hard and and done what they
thought they were doing
have had their property
effectively stolen from them by state
action
and it has been this fig leaf that we're
going to help the ratepayers because
we're lowering rates for the utilities
an infinitesimal amount and almost half
of that amount going to private
corporations like Constellation Energy
and Direct Energy which has nothing to
do with the rate payers or the rates
that they pay that simply helps their
bottom line
so
so my next question is about the
language that says distribution
utilities shall submit to the commission
the following
a list of color customer cited sources
eligible for et cetera et cetera Etc
doesn't that mean that the customer has
to
contact the utility and indicate that
they are a source
of eligible class one certification if
they don't do that then
the utility has no obligation to submit
to the commission their name because
they don't have it
isn't that true
of it
it's a little more complicated than that
and the other um fig leaf that has been
put forward here is that these people
received rebates anyone who received a
rebate there will be a rebate
application with their name and their
address so any affected customer
generator who received a rebate that
information would be on file with the
utility again you're suggesting that
someone who knows nothing of this
provision should be taking affirmative
action to reach out to the utility to
inform them of information that they
should know
yeah actually what I was suggesting is
that the language of this rule says that
it's up to the customer to notify you
the utility
that's the language of the
of the rule
I also have a question about you said
that
the last section of the bill imposes no
cost on the state because the
distribution utilities would be the ones
who had would be required to do the
mailings
but distribution utilities can recover
their costs and rates so
there might not be any direct costs to
the state but that fifteen thousand
dollars is going to be recovered from
customers no matter what
does that kind of cost six cents on the
average dollar uh residence average bill
does that come under a fiscal note
fiscal notes or costs to the state
are they not oh I think fiscal notes can
be costs in general I don't think
I've certainly never seen that but uh
another another issue which the legal
experts who could be brought in to
consider this matter such that we would
not be imposing dramatic costs not
infinitesimal costs on taxpayers might
be a better way to go forward than to
ask me questions that are better
directed to a lawyer maybe the doe can
shed some light on that question since
the doe presented this information I
don't think we will see a solution from
them
okay representative Summers has a
question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question now I'll be the first
to admit I am not a lawyer I have
questions though on page two of lines 25
through 28 in regards to the Federal
Trade Commission and then uh excuse me
are you on the handout or the bill the
actual bill the actual bill page two
lines 25-28 thank you and on here this
is the meat of the penalty where it says
that uh the Federal Trade Commission can
basically
find you guilty of false advertising if
you mark your home businesses running a
renewable energy that you generate
failure to comply with resulting FTC
order May subject to your business civil
penalties up to ten thousand for every
day the violation continues so then I
was looking this up under the Federal
Trade Commission and I found the Federal
Trade Commission states that the uh the
commission can seek civil penalties if
it proves the company knew the conduct
was unfair or deceptive in violation
of a particular FTC Act and the FTC
already issued a written decision that
such conduct is unfair or deceptive do
you know if there's actually an FTC act
or a written uh fine Court finding on
any of the of this pertaining to uh
solar Renewables yes and it has been
presented previously and was referenced
in the HB 234 I didn't bring that
information with me today because I was
quite certain that the chair would
direct me to speak to this bill rather
than that bill
um so yes there are cases and in fact
it's the FTC guidance which cites legal
cases again it's it's not a likely
um
I I think what what you're looking at
when they say the FCC can do the
following it's it is um
not exclusive it is it it it it it gives
you things that it can do but it doesn't
say that's all it can do and because of
the guidance that we have discovered and
which I can send you the reference to uh
we know that in fact they the
presumption is
you can't even have a picture of the
solar array of your business
and say nothing about it being renewably
run because the presumption is that if
you had the picture with your solar
panels that you were the presumption is
that you're advertising yourself as
being run by renewable energy but in
fact if you've sold your wrecks or if
they've been taken from you
you are falsely making that claim
okay thank you
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um actually this is a comment directed
towards uh you although I truly support
the intent of this bill there seemed to
be some fairly large discrepancies with
the fiscal note and the information
presented and I'd like to ask for a
subcommittee to address these issues
okay thank you thank you representative
representative randles I know you had
your hand up but you're a a co-sponsor
of this bill so we're not allowed you're
not allowed to ask questions
um
additional questions
Mr chair
representative muns thank you um no just
to follow up on representative Wendy
Thomas I'm I'm assuming that if we did
have a subcommittee that we could also
look at the exact language that's
um included on
page two which is the actual notice
correct
I mean the the important point of this
piece of legislation is that notice
should be provided the exact wording of
the notice is something that we can
certainly talk about in a subcommittee I
would think
yeah so some committee could certainly
talk about that thank you absolutely
any additional questions
for
non-representative The Honorable
representative
representative cloje has a question
uh thank you chair thank you uh MS oksan
if this does go
through this bill
does it not notify in the consumer
generator and if they still do not does
not do nothing do they have a legal
recourse now
because they have been notified
it's a very interesting question it's
never occurred to me that someone who
was notified would
not be interested in taking protective
action
um
once again perhaps the subcommittee
could resolve that issue for us
it's a good question
follow-up
thank you
um
myself reading it
if I wasn't taking the wrecks now or not
metering
the attributes I would look discard it
the question
to you is
would
the sweat sweeping still
be allowed to those if they're abandoned
thank you
I wish the the word abandoned it had
never come up because it's it's such a
red herring it really has nothing to do
with the issue when a customer generator
invests in their equipment and they
establish it on their property there is
a presumption that they have the
property that they have the renewable
energy that is being generated that they
can
if they sell the house they can say oh
and look it's you know has renewable
energy
if a person is informed that actually
the state is making it impossible for
them to even claim that they've been
using renewable energy for the 10 years
that they've been living on the property
and thinking that they were using
renewable energy
I think I went down to rabbit hole and
and lost where that sentence was going
um the
central issue is the renewable
attributes which are the property
interest they have never been lost
they were generated they were created at
the moment of generation and they had
been taken by the state action away from
the customer generator without their
knowledge the notification enables them
to know that this is occurring now is a
another issue which you've certainly
created in my mind which is what happens
to the person who doesn't read the
notification you know they they will be
in the same position that they are now
if the statute is allowed to stand but
it's certainly my hope that out of this
subcommittee there will be a recognition
that this is a provision which no longer
should be in New Hampshire law and no
one will be subject to it in the future
could the chair indulge me
I will indulge you since we do have time
thank you
um
so there's actually a third
thing that hasn't been discussed until
now if I understand it right
so the customer generator
now knowing they have attributes
had because they've been taken they
still haven't at this time I believe
they haven't have not been slept oh they
have been if you have if you are a
customer generator your renewable
attributes have been swept from the
moment that you started operating
foreign
did that answer your question no may I
continue
well we don't I'm good we don't engage
in debate we we ask questions it was a
question for clarification understanding
all right I'll allow it and
the customer generator
if it's not if they are not
net metered
they are
this is under the net metering statute
then there if they are net meter
and they don't
if they don't sell their wrecks
they just keep getting them
is is that that question is is that the
point you're trying to make so if they
want to keep them
they are not available to be slipped
it may
thank you it it is it is the case that
by registering
and spending that money and having that
industrial meter in your front yard and
all of those onerous things by doing
that you can protect your renewable
attributes from being swept any longer
you it you're protecting yourself from
the moment at which they stop doing it
but they're already
and have been doing it for a decade
representative partial has a question
thank you chair
um do I understand correctly that the
two parts way ma uh do I understand
correctly
that having Rex does not necessarily
mean that I need to sell those racks I
can register the Rex and decide to
retain them for my own enjoyment
whatever that may be
you could if you wanted to fill out all
the forms have the work done on your
property pay the money you could do that
and get the satisfaction of nobody being
able to use this provision of law
against you
yeah and a follow-up I may
go ahead
um
if I want to take these wrecks I do need
to purchase equipment in order to
measure a meter is aware
uh however
when the wrecks are swept
they use their information independent
of what of what that meter says so
there's an expense some say maybe an
owner's expense on me in order to
register those racks that the power
company does not incur by sweeping them
yes and if you were if you wanted to
sell your wrecks you could only sell
your excess production the the net that
you put out whereas when they're
sweeping the wrecks they take everything
even what you used inside your business
or inside your home because it's a
calculation based on the name plate
times the capacity Factor times the
number of hours of a year and that is
a number which is the maximum possible
thank you
representative muns asked a question so
as a follow-up to that question if um if
someone chose to sell their wrecks then
that would be income that they would
have to help them offset some of their
other expenses their any utility bills
that they're paying or other expenses
correct yes I'll take my own facility
just as
you know as an example I produce one
megawatt a year
so going through all this in order to
get one wreck
when I don't even think they were
selling for twenty dollars
I just did there there's no reason why
any
reasonably uh
penny pinching
good Yankee would would undertake such a
measure
so that's probably why 40 percent of
people eligible don't bother to collect
their wrecks correct
it's not about collecting
wrecks are a representation of the
renewable attributes the renewable
attributes are there they're produced
just every time electricity is produced
by that generator the question is who
owns those renewable attributes and for
I would say most of the 40 percent have
no idea of even what a wreck is much
less that they've or a renewable
attribute or the fact that they do not
in fact generate renewable energy in
their home or business they think they
do
okay
so you know further questions I'd like
to call forward and I'd like to thank
the honorable uh thank you the oxenham
for her testimony here I'd like to call
forward Griffin Roberge from the
Department of energy to give us their
take on this bill
foreign
thank you chairman both members of the
committee uh Griffin Roberts again from
the New Hampshire Department of energy
the department is neutral on this bill
is introduced
um the bill requires the department to
notify customer generators who are not
rec certified under class one and two
that their production has been credited
under the statutory provision that was
subject to a public hearing on House
Bill 234 I believe
um
under section two of the bill doe is
required to issue an annual notice to
customer generators that their
production has been credited against
electric providers RPS obligations under
classes one and two the notice shall
inform customer generators of their
options to get certified to create
wrecks and the consequences of having
their production credited
the other part of section 2 page one
lines
17-24 also require any person who
interconnects as a customer generator at
a later date be noticed that the
prediction that their production will be
credited unless they become Rec
certified the notice will inform
customer generators again of their
options to get certified uh to create
wrecks and the consequences of having
their production credited
um page one lines 28
to throughout the entirety of page two
uh include language that Doe must
prominently include and they're written
notice to these customer generators and
then on page three sub paragraph d uh
permits doe to fulfill its duties under
the bill by passing this written notice
responsibility onto electric
distribution companies
um Dewey does want to note some
observations from the bills fiscal note
which I know has been mentioned already
Department would agree that it is would
contend that it is in fact difficult to
get accurate data on how many customer
generators are interconnected and are
not producing Rex the interconnection
process is largely done through
utilities when when customer generators
interconnect they are not filing regular
information with the New Hampshire
Department of energy utilities are the
ones going out and interconnecting these
resources onto their infrastructure
um per the bills fiscal note we do
assume that there are roughly 14 000
customer generators in the state that
are that may be eligible to produce Rex
but again due to the inconsistencies and
how this data is kept
um we can't provide an actual figure for
how many customer generators are not
producing class one or two Rex
um we also as I mentioned we do not
receive any information about
interconnections as this is done
entirely through the utilities
um again per the bills fiscal note
getting a list of specific customer
generators who are interconnected not
registered will not be an easy
undertaking there is no shared form of
identification between the data
available between doe and the data held
by utilities matching up these lists
will be a significant undertaking for
administrative staff within our
sustainable energy division who already
have a Litany of other tasks to do on a
day-to-day basis
based again on the fiscal note and this
is just for the actual mailings and the
postage and whatnot for this notice
requirement the annual cost to send
these notices would be around fifteen
thousand dollars should doe be unable to
come up with the funds for just the
administrative mailing costs or the
administrative staffing needs in order
to complete this um the responsibility
would likely be passed on to electric
distribution companies under the
provisions on page three
utilities as is noted would likely pass
that cost onto their ratepayers to cover
the cost for these annual mailings
um
regarding the written notice itself
which is
prominently on page two the language
does not reference any statutory
Provisions or resources for customer
generators to understand the RPS most
significantly lines 18 to 28 on page two
indicate that the customer generator may
be undertaking illegal activity and is
subject to civil penalties of up to ten
thousand dollars a day the notice
includes no reference to any federal
rule or statute allowing for the Federal
Trade Commission to undertake this
action I I think the department would
contend that the threat of a ten
thousand dollar fine will alarm electric
customers in the state and they will
want more information as to where that
Authority is derived and as previously
discussed in the house bill 234 public
hearing getting Rec certified is not an
easy task there are a lack of
independent monitors in the state to do
indiv to do in-person Rec certification
for the for facilities there's also
there are existing options to get
inverse murders or utility meters to
measure production but again doing so
comes at an additional cost additionally
customer generators may have already
decided not to register as they see the
value of Class 2 Rex is pretty low
because of a high Supply so it may not
be financially viable for them to spend
these upfront costs to get Rec certified
pay for ongoing monitoring services but
only get a very modest income from
selling your wrecks
um
finally the notice implies at its
conclusion on page two lines 29 to 36
that customer generators should get Rec
certified and then not sell their wrecks
to electric suppliers this notice could
potentially have cut again have customer
generators pay significant cost for rec
certification but they receive no
benefit from that certification as they
cannot sell their wrecks to electric
electric suppliers as is being advocated
in the notice it might also confuse
customers because they might believe
that the notice constitutes or
represents a legal requirement to
register in order to create wrecks under
the RPS when no such requirement for
interconnection exists in order to get
Rec certified and with that I'm happy to
take any questions I will start out and
say I am not an attorney I will be very
limited in what I can offer about the
constitutionality of things but more
than willing to take a shot at any
questions that are offered
thank you appreciate your testimony uh
representative partial has a question
it's like a chair of those
um once again I'm hearing about the
depressed prices on uh
the value of Iraq
and I am thus thinking about just supply
and demand if I'm out there selling
apples as an example for an analogy and
the guy next door gets his apples that's
by sneaking my yard at night
and be able to sell them without any
over cost from my tree it's not going to
depress the price of what I can charge
for my apples so thank you for the
question so apples aside I'm just
shifting it back to class two right well
that's okay I'm using the same analogy
here so thank you fine
um but class two Rex uh prices you know
I think in talking with our sustainable
energy division typically vary between
three dollars to six dollars a wreck and
again a wreck is measured based on one
megawatt hour of production so for a
small residential system over the course
of a year that output can be very very
small so
um in terms of the uh reduced cost of
Class 2 Rex there are a number of
factors that go into that obviously the
crediting mechanism that currently
exists as was proposed in House Bill 234
plays A Part the overall abundance of
Class 2 Rex also plays a role as well as
well as the current obligation level for
Class 2 playwrack player play a role
sorry
thank you
additional questions for the Department
representative Corman has one thank you
Mr chairman and I just want to
make sure I'm clear on something you
said earlier when you were talking about
um that the utilities do know who these
customer generators are
but
there's just some interoperability
issues with doe with the systems At Doe
is is that it it's a matter of of just
getting the information into the correct
format or is there more to it than that
sure so thank you for the question
um again doe is not going out with
trucks and Crews interconnecting you
know customer generators and their
facilities onto the grid that is done
through utility so utilities
predominantly have that information if
the goal was to have doe conduct this uh
conduct these notices themselves which
obviously there is a provision to pass
it along to distribution utilities but
if there was the obligation for doe to
assume itself it would require
significant administrative staff time to
consult with utilities match up their
lists with any type of data that we
might have on the con on customer
generators operating in the state and
then split out who who's already
registered to create Rex and who's not
registered to create Rex
foreign
representative Kaplan has a question
yeah just a follow-up on yeah thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question Mr Roberts
um just to follow up on that uh I just
I'm still having a problem squaring the
um the information that we heard earlier
based on the the administrative rules
that there is a list submitted to the
commission
um of customer cited Source eligible for
certification and that that
presumably that information is available
already in the commission
and so what what is the difficulty
getting a hold of a list of people who
are eligible for Rex this is just
parsing the ones who have already
applied for Rex and have received them
from that list I mean it doesn't seem to
be a huge administrative lift no thank
you for the question
um I would respectfully contend in
talking with our sustainable energy
division that this would be a lift
um the lists the list again the
utilities largely have this information
I cannot point to any
um information that might have been
shared prior about administrative rules
I can certainly talk with folks
internally and get back to the committee
on on the the rules that were mentioned
previous testimony but as far as I know
in talking with our sustainable energy
division is that they are not day to day
looking through a master list of all the
interconnected sources registered in the
state who register who is Rec certified
and who isn't trying to develop
processes and the mechanism to do that
on an annual basis for these notices
would
take a significant amount of
administrative time especially for our
sustainable folks with which there's
only really four staffers day to day
doing this type of work
thank you I know you said earlier that
you're not a lawyer
and neither am I but do you have any
idea what in
administrative rule 2503.04
a customer cited
s-i-t-e-t-s-i-t-e-d source is does that
do you know what the definition of that
is does that just mean if I'm a customer
who has a an on-site solar array is that
what that means if I could what was the
rule again I'm sorry
2503.04 net metering credit
I'm sorry I don't have that handout but
what I can do is I can I've written down
the rule here I can certainly take a
look at that and follow back up with the
committee if that's okay okay great
thank you
all right so you know further questions
from the committee
and having no more pink cards
I will ask if there's anybody sitting in
the audience who would like to speak on
this issue
seeing none
I'll close the public hearing on House
Bill 263 FN and ask representative
closure to give us an indication as to
the blue sheet recommendations
uh thank you chair
I'll spill two six three
the blue sheet two and support none of
pose
online
63 in support three oppose
thank you
okay thank you with that I'd say we're
done
4 18 not a bad day's work
we'll be back here tomorrow morning at
nine o'clock to start all over again see
you then and have a pleasant evening